nous reprenons je rappelle que après les
règles que nous avons arrêté que j'ai
arrêté tout à l'heure avant la reprise
ce sera une minute ce soir pour l'
prentation des amendements comme pour le
rebond et on commence par l'amendement
1007 de Monsieur Lucas merci Monsieur le
le président en une minute rapide la
liste des métiers d' ention et notre
point de vue assez contestable nombre de
nombreux corps de métiers n'y figurent
pas alors que tous les professionnels
des secteurs concernés s'accordent à
dire qu'il peinent à recruter c'est
d'ailleurs ce que nous disions dès le la
version initiale de V de votre texte que
cette espèce de pseudo compensation
humanime qui humaniste pardon j'en perd
mes moyens le retour du ministre qui me
qui me qui me fait perdre mes moyens non
le le C cette pseudo compensation
humaniste à un texte extrêmement brutal
ne nous apparaissait évidemment pas
satisfaisante dès l'origine cet
amendement vise à évaluer l'impact
qu'aurait la prise en compte de nouveaux
métiers dans ces cette liste de métiers
en tension tant pour le secteur
économique que pour l'accueil des
étrangers en France monsieur le
rapporteur oui je je ne vois pas
l'intérêt d'avoir ce genre d'indication
dans le rapport dans le Parlement
débattra chaque année mais en revanche
nous aurons vous le savez mon cher
collègue et et je l'espère longuement et
de façon approfondie un débat à
l'occasion de l'article 4 bis pour
lequel vous le savez j'ai déposé un
amendement il y a déjà plusieurs heures
défavorable je mets au voix qui va être
pour contre rejeté le suivant le 1008
encore plus rapide monsieur le le
président pour donner suite à votre
souhait que nous avancions rapidement
euh nous souhaitons attirer l'attention
du Gouvernement sur le manque criant de
moyens octroyer aux préfectures pour le
traitement des demandes qu'elles doivent
instruire nous sommes ici toutes et tous
les réceptacles de ces réalité je
connais déjà votre votre réponse à venir
monsieur le ministre comme ça a déjà été
évoqué tout à l'heure et que ça le sera
encore sans doute par la suite je vais
néanmoins défendre cette cet amendement
qui qui propose d'intégrer cette donnée
à la réflexion globale d'un rapport pour
définir la politique migratoire de la
France encore faut-il savoir si elle a
les moyens de l'appliquer monsieur le
rapporteur encore plus rapide
défavorable monsieur monrat oui je pense
que notre collègue Lucas quand même
cible dans la volonté de ce rapport que
vous nous imposer on aurait préféré le
supprimer cette critique essentielle qui
est que oui on a augmenté légèrement le
nombre de fonctionnaires lorsqu'on a
fait laalopmie mais ce n'est pas
suffisant par rapport à la
nécessité réelle qu'il y a pour nos
services publics il y a aussi un autre
moyen qu'on pourrait aussi dev voir de
libéralisation si je peux me permettre
de la façon dont on traite les étrangers
en France dans la pour donner des titres
de séjour pour le droit d'asile et je
pense que il y a à la fois une logique
de simplification je sais que c'est un
terme qui plaît beaucoup à monsieur le
ministre mais il y a aussi une logique
de service public et le service public
est vraiment à mal dans notre pays je
crois que c'est le grand défi du 21e
siècle de réinvestir le service public
intégralement et pas seulement avec 400
fonctionnair mais peut-être en
rétablissant les 4000 qui ont été
supprimés à l'époque de Monsieur
Hollande mais j'enis pas comptable je le
mets au voix qui vote pour qui vote
contre rejeté le suivant le 100 monsieur
bien merci Monsieur le le président euh
il y a les collègues du rassemblement
national parlent beaucoup de ce terme
mais il y a un grand remplacement bien
réel celui-ci qui est celui des
individus des agents du service public
des fonctionnaires des êtres humains en
somme par des machines et à travers cet
amendement nous souhaitons
interpeller le le gouvernement et nous
souhaitons qu'il y a une réflexion dans
le cadre de ce rapport qui sera qui
serait remis au Parlement sur les
conséquences déléternes d'une
dématérialisation des démarches pour la
prise en charge des demandes euh tout le
monde n'a pas une un accès stable à une
connexion Internet euh et donc il nous
paraît indispensable d'intégrer cette
cette réflexion qui d'ailleurs fait écho
à ce qui a pu être exprimé sur ce sujet
ou sur d'autres par le Défenseur des
droits euh notamment sur la
dématérialisation nous nous croyons et
je le dis euh de devant ma collègue et
camarade al fosson que l'humain d'abord
ça peut-être un beau slogan y compris
pour le pour le service public et y
compris pour les matières dont nous
traitons ce soir
oui c'est bien le droit existant il faut
à la fois un accompagnement et des
solutions alternatives le Conseil d'État
l'a rappelé il y a déjà quelques années
donc c'est tout à fait satisfait par
ailleurs ce rapport qui sera présenté
oralement n'est pas un rapport au
Parlement pardon n'est pas un rapport
d'évaluation je pense que ça n'est pas
la place de l'amendement que vous
évoquez défavorable monsieur carrat
pardon madame
fon merci Monsieur le le président
pendant des années j'ai vu devant la
préfecture de mon département celui des
des hautes scènes des des fils d'attente
très longues très tôt dans le froid avec
y compris des des personnes qui venaient
profiter de de de cette misère pour
vendre des places dehors et la
dématérialisation a pour une part à la
fois évidemment répondu à à ces à ces
difficultés mais elle a aussi
invisibilisé
l'attente de très nombreux demandeurs et
et d'ailleurs elle n'a pas effacé
complètement les trafics puisque on a eu
de très nombreuses personnes qui ont
profité de ce
système informatique pour y compris
continuer à vendre des places de
rendez-vous pendant un certain temps euh
ce que ce que je constate aujourd'hui
c'est que à la fois la dématérialisation
elle éloigne un certain nombre de
personnes les plus vulnérables la
Défenseur des droits le dit et
évidemment les étrangers dans ce pays
font partie aussi des plus vulnérables
elle les met dans dans des grandes
difficultés mais nous ce qu'on essaie de
vous dire parce que la dématérialisation
on y voit aussi des avantages pour
beaucoup de citoyens c'est que quand
elle devient un désagrément il faut
pouvoir l'accompagner par des moyens
humains euh et c'est aussi ce que dit
d'ailleurs la la Défenseur des droits on
nous a expliqué qu'il y aurait de
l'accueil en préfecture bon moi d'abord
dans ma préfecture pour y rentrer faut
avoir un rendez-vous donc déjà faut
avoir pris rendez-vous pour pouvoir
accéder à l'informatique et ensuite une
fois que vous y êtes en fait on ne vous
a êtes pas vraiment dans les démarches
on vous aide pour accéder aux démarches
donc on voit bien que cette
dématérialisation aujourd'hui elle
accompagne en tout cas une forme
d'exclusion des plus vulnérables vers un
service public il faut pouvoir y
répondre en fait c'est c'est vrai pour
les étrangers c'est vrai pour tous les
citoyens de ce pays et le traitement
finalement des étrangers est à l'image
et bien de de du traitement qui est qui
est infligé à bon nombre de personnes
dans ce pays je pense aux plus âgés je
pense parfois aux plus pauvres enfin
mais mais beaucoup de gens sont sont
concernés il faut pouvoir y répondre bon
c'était le dernier cas dans prentation à
2 minutes qui vote pour qui vote contre
rejeté le 105 monsieur
Lucas merci merci chers collègues merci
monsieur le Président non ça ne bon je
peux essayer quand même mais on m'entend
quand même comme ça peut-être de façon
plus prend l'autre allez voilà c'est pas
grave c'est pas grave grave euh c'est le
c'est c'est le le fond du propos qui
compte et pas et pas mon visage
euh on
connaî non je ne fais pas de la
politique pour l'image parler il aun
minute bien simplement sur un sujet qui
en plus est un sujet très très sérieux
ça a été rappelé abondamment par les
collègues du rassemblement national les
chiffres des sondages de l'opinion et
CER l'opinion telle qu'on la fabrique
effectivement semble adhérer à un
certain nombre de fantasmes et de
contrevérité sur les questions
migratoires nous nous croyons qu'un
débat éclairé qu'un débat apaisé qu'un
débat fondé sur d'excellentes lectures
comme nous le suggérait le le collègue
Kerbrat notamment de de François erand
sur des réalités statistiques permettrai
aux françaises et aux Français de savoir
qu'en réalité les présupposés qui
président à la à la rédaction de ce
texte initial ou de ce texte
horrifié par le par le Sénat et bien que
tout ça permettrait d'avoir une
finalement un débat raisonné apaisé
sur la vérité les Français verrai bien
qu'il n'y a pas de submersion migratoire
je mets des guillemets que laappel d'
n'existe pas je je ne reviens pas ici
sur les débats que nous avons eu ce
matin et donc cet amendement visa à
étudier l'impact qu'aurait c'est une
proposition c'est une SME d'appel pour
qu'on envisage la possibilité d'une
convention citoyenne sur l'immigration
comme leur proposé de nombreuses
associations merci monsieur le
rapporteur mais on peut débattre de
l'intérêt des conventions citoyennes
d'ailleurs pour l'immigration d'autres
sujets pourquoi pas mais ce n'est pas ce
que vous proposez vous demandez au
gouvernement de rendre compte des des
conséquences éventuelles qu'aurait sur
le débat parlementaire une convention
citoyenne sur l'immigration qui n'existe
pas et par ailleurs je vous rappelle que
lorsque la
Convention sur le climat a été créée
elle a été par le CZ et pas par le
gouvernement il avait une initiative
évidemment présidentiel comme vous savez
et je ne pense pas qu'il revienne au
Parlement d'une certaine façon de
lui-même prévoir que un tiers des des
battant qui a toute sa légitimité soit
lui sohait imposer dans son propre débat
préalable je crois que ça n'est pas très
cohérent donc
défavorable alors madame
Diaz merci monsieur le Président moi je
trouve C nos collègues de laanupes bien
naïf ils appellent de leur vœux une
convention citoyenne mais je veux dire
on a déjà été éprouvé par le
gouvernement on sait très bien que la
convention citoyenne sur le climat n'a
rien donné on sait très bien que le
grand débat n'a rien donné et que les
rencontres de Saint-Denis ne donnent
rien non plus alors plutôt que
d'invoquer un anem gadget de convention
citoyenne nous nous leur disons écoutez
soutenez les propositions la proposition
formulée par Marine Le Pen c'est-à-dire
de proposer un référendum au français
pour qu'il s'exprime sur le sujet mais
je pense que vous aurez un avis sur la
question puisque le 9 juin prochain à
l'occasion des élections européennes les
Français seront consulter et s'ils
considèent qu'il y a trop d'immigration
en France ils pourront voter pour la
liste de Jordane Bardella madame
jeunev merci monsieur le Président je
suis moi aussi très réservée sur l'appel
à cette convention citoyenne mais
permettez-moi de dire à nos collègues
LFI que je trouve assez savoureuse leur
invitation à un débat
apaisé monsieur Lucas
nous sommes nous sommes ma chère
collègue extrêmement apaisés depuis
cette reprise je comprends pas très bien
cette cette provocation inutile
simplement pour dire à monsieur le
rapporteur vous voyez vous dites
vous-même que mon amendement était très
timide très timoré qu'il va donc vous
voyez ça ça prouve qu'on peut être
constructif et donc je propose un
premier pas pour réfléchir à ce que
seraient les conséquences éventuelles de
voyez que on est là dans une forme de
coconstruction dont vous seriez bien
inspiré de de saisir la main qui vous
est
tendue je le mets au voix qui vote pour
contre rejeté euh le 462 monsieur
housoussin oui si vous voulez bien je
vais vous présenter le 462 et le 463 en
même temps alors le 462 c'est un
amendement qui vous propose de comparer
le coûpt moyen d'une demande d'asile
déposée à l'étranger d'une demande
d'asil déposée sur le territoire
français vous savez euh nous sommes
attachés au droit d'asile nous pensons
cependant qu'il est quelque peu dévoyé
qu'il devient quelque part l'une des
filières d'immigration illégale en
raison en fait du nombre de personnes
qui sont déboutées de leur demande
d'asile mais qui restent sur le
territoire français nous nous pensons
que nous devons dans la très grande
majorité des cas euh organiser le
traitement des demandes d'asile dans les
ambassades dans les consulats que ça
soit dans les pays d'origine euh ou dans
les pays limitrophes ça nous éviterait
une problématique quand même importante
euh on a quelques chiffres qui datent un
petit peu ce 2015 de la Cour des comptes
qui estimit que 96 % des personnes
déboutées du droit d'asile resta en
France ce qui est considérable ce qui
m'amène par la même occasion donc à
l'amendement 463 parce que justement
l'amendement 463 il demande que dans le
rapport on ait le nombre total de
déboutés du droit d'asile bon ça c'est
plutôt une information qu'on peut avoir
mais parmi ceux-ci la proportion qui
quitte effectivement le territoire
français parce que le chiffre que je
viens de vous vous donner date quand
même on a à peu près 150000 demandes
d'asile par an et nous aimerions savoir
parmi les déboutés combien quitte
effectivement en notre pays et avoir des
chiffres actualisés la Cour des comptes
a été capable d'en produire en 2015
c'est donc il y a bien un moyen d'en
obtenir monsieur le rapporteur vos deux
avis oui notre collègue député Solignac
il y a quelques heures s'interroger sur
votre méconnaissance ou plutôt oui
totale meséconnaissance des phénomènes
migratoires il n'y a pas de demande
d'asile à l'étranger qui serit
enregistré jamais ça n'existe pas il y a
le cas échéant des visas qui sont
délivrés par nos organismes consulaires
pour que la personne puisse venir en
France et enregistre demande qui sera
analysé par le mais ça n'existe pas ce
que vous dites monsieur le député
défavorable monsieur
carat ou madame Tor l'un des deux
seulement
oui prenons le cas d'une femme afghane
dans le régime
taliban voudrait faire une demande
d'asile en France suite aux violences
contre les femmes qui sont faites en
Afghanistan elle ne pourrait pas malgré
tout ce que peut nous dire le Front
national imaginons une personne
homosexuelle LGBTI qui souhaiterait
faire une demande d'asile en Iran pour
profiter pour être protégé euh voilà moi
de toute façon je vous redis ce que vous
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure vous
n'êtes pas crédible sur le droit d'asile
quand votre président de parti monsieur
Bardella dit qu'il ne voit pas la
plusvalue d'accueillir les femmes
afghanes écoutez c'est du droit
international c'est de la protection des
personnes nous on ne gère pas les gens
dans le droit d'asile sur la plusvalue
on les gère par rapport à leur régime de
protection de droit donc c'est
totalement absurde et les demandes
d'asile doivent s'organiser en France
via des visas et nous proposerons un
amendement par exemple sur les couloirs
humanitaires qui est une pratique qui
existe déjà il y a un agrément de
certaines associations avec le ministère
de l'Intérieur et les préf et les et les
consulats pour pouvoir organiser ça et
bien c'est quelque chose que je trouve
beaucoup plus logique que de faire des
demandes d'asile dans des pays qui son
contre les protection non oui je on a
déjà eu ce débat en commission des lois
je sais plus sur quel lequel de vos
textes du rassemblement national et et
vous vous nous vous nous aviez fait
cette même proposition donc ça va dans
le sens de Monsieur Kerbrat imaginez
vous êtes un opposant politique au
taliban en Afghanistan alors vous allez
prendre vous allez aller vous rendre au
consulat mais il y a plus ça tombe mal
il y a plus de consulat en il y a plus
de consulade parce qu'il y a les taliban
donc alors qu'est-ce que vous allez
faire vous allez partir à Islamabad et
puis là Islam
comme il y aura beaucoup de demandes de
de de de de de gens qui veulent avoir
l'asile vous aurez une grande queue
voilà une longue queue et puis comme ça
les talibans bah avec leurs amis
pourront regarder qui est dans la queue
et puis s'occuper de les prendre et de
les ramener au pays c'est complètement
stupide c'est tout le contraire de ce
qu'est l'asile l'asile c'est l'accueil
de gens qui sont en que nous devons
protéger dans notre pays au titre de la
Convention de Genève 1951 cette
convention est issue de la guerre elle
est issue de la guerre 39 45 vous êtes
vous êtes ridicule merci Monsieur
housoussin alors moi je vais reprendre
votre exemple si je pars d'Iran ou je
pars d'Afghanistan il me semble je sais
pas que vous avez pas écouté ce qu'on
vous disait soit dans les pays d'origine
soit dans les pays limitrophes ou les
pays de la route de migration quand vous
êtes en Afghanistan ou en Iran il est
quand même plus facile de faire votre
demande d'asile dans un pays limitrophe
il y a quand même moins de migration à
faire que de venir jusqu'en France donc
a priori c'est plutôt plus facile que
moins monsur le rapporteur
monsieurousin ce n'est pas ce que vous
demandez à votre amendement vous
demandez le coût moyen des demandes
d'asile qui sont faites à l'étranger ça
n'existe
pas alors le 462 qui vote pour qui vote
contre rejeté le 463 même vote le 86 pas
défendu le 266 monsieur Hadad merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je vous propose un amendement
de la commission des affaires étrangères
qui a été adoptée pour avis la semaine
dernière qui propose de rajouter au
rapport une évaluation de la dimension
ex des migrations et notamment des
causes structurelles qui sont à
l'origine des mouvements migratoires on
pense bien sûr aux questions
sécuritaires économique climatique à
l'utilisation aussi desmigration comme
un instrument hybride par des régimes
autoritaires comme la Biélorussie cette
évaluation permettra de continuer à
éclairer le travail de de transparence
qui est ce ce rapport et de contrôle
démocratique dans ce rapport annuel au
Parlement mais aussi de montrer une fois
de plus qu'il n'y a pas de solution dans
le repli nationaliste sur la question
migratoire mais que ça passe au
contraire par la coopération bien
européenne et
internationale monsieur monsieur porte
merci monsieur le Président ici un
amendement effectivement pour inclure
des éléments permettant d'évaluer la
situation des réfugiés climatiques et
des répercussions du réchauffement
climatique sur les causes migratoires je
sais que dans cette salle certains nient
le changement climatique mais c'est une
des données majeures des migration de
demain en 2022 il y a eu 32 millions de
déplacés climatiques dans le monde le
réchauffement climatique entraîne des
migrations qu'il faut anticiper il faut
anticiper l'accueil parce que nous
aurons à accueillir des gens ici
l'accueil j'ai l'impression que c'est un
gros mot depuis le débuts des débats que
nous avons et puis aussi ça nous
permettra peut-être d'avoir des éléments
sur les causes de ce réchauffement
climatique et de remettre en cause le
système capitaliste qui crée des
inégalités 84 % de l'économie mondiale
est dans 20 pays et on a aujourd'hui des
gens qui alimentent des thèses racistes
dans ce pays et notamment Vincent Boloré
qui va en Afrique piller ses pays et qui
après dénonce le fait que des gens qui
l'a exploité privés de toutes les
ressources viennent en France donc nous
avons besoin d'avoir un une étude
aujourd'hui sur l'impact euh de de du
réchauffement climatique et sur les
causes migratoires monsieur
Lucas merci Monsieur le le président
également pour demander qu'on prenne en
compte cette réalité il y a quelques
heures à peine le secrétaire général de
l'ONU a appelé à briser le cycle
meurtrier du réchauffement cela prouve
bien qu'il y a un cycle meurtrier à
l'œuvre du Grand réchauffement bien réel
là aussi celui-ci qui va bouleverser le
monde tel que nous le connaissons qui le
bouleverse d'ailleurs déjà et donc nous
appelons à ce que cette donnée- là qui
est absente il faut le dire des
réflexions d'un grand nombre de groupes
ici soit au cœur en réalité de nos
réflexions sur la place qui est la
notôre dans le monde notre capacité à
accueillir et sur le rôle aussi qui est
le nôtre face à ce grand dérangement du
monde à ce ces grands bouleversements
liés au
réchauffement
climatique monsur
rapporteur oui ces amendements en
discussion commune je préfère le
l'amendement de la commission des
affaires étrangères euh oui parce
qu'elle a rendu un avis madame la
députée déjà et cet avis a été débattu
et a été adopté par la commission et
affffaires étrangères il est plus large
monsieur Lucas monsieur porte que le
vôre c'est-à-dire il s'intéresse au
cause structurel et à l'origine des
mouvements migratoires dont bien sûr la
cause climatique elle est évidemment
intégrée donc avis favorable au 266
c'est défavorable aux autres mais pour
les raisons que je viens d'indiquer
monsieur le ministre non sur ce point
trois choses et d'ailleurs ça fait écho
au débat qu'on a eu au Sénat le premier
c'est incontestablement les réfléchés
climatiques sont nombreux et sert de
plus en plus nombreux entre 24 et 30
millions de personnes par an entre 60000
et 100000 personnes par jour et qui
touche en premier vous l'avez dit dans
le débat introductif dans la discussion
autour de de l'audition que vous avez
bien voulu
commettre autour du fait que c'est
d'abord les pays du Sud entre eux qui
connaissent ses réfugiés et la France
aura en connaître sans doute d'abord
dans ce territoire ultrabarin notamment
ce qui touche l'Océanie en premier lieu
donc incontestablement ces réfugiés
climatiques sont déjà un sujet d'accueil
c'est le cas notamment de la deuxème
demande d'asile qu'on a en France le
Bangladesh qui est en partie en partie
seulement mais en partie quand même
autour des des questions climatiques et
va être de plus en plus important
deuxièmement à part l'Australie à ma
connaissance aucun autre pays au monde
n'a réfléchi à l'accueil de ces réf
climatique en les définissant comme une
sorte de droit d'asile climatique donc
le monde et sans doute l'ONU que vous
avez cité monsieur le député mais aussi
c'est le cas sans doute de la CEDH qui
mériterait de revoir une partie de son
fonctionnement parce que comme ça a été
très bien dit ça a été fait au lendemain
de la guerre pour des réfugiés
politiques et là on voit bien qu'il y a
des réfugiés religieux des réfugiés
d'orientation sexuelle et puis des
réfugiés on l'a dit climatique qui
mériteraiit d'adapter ce qui fait notre
asile occidental ou en tout cas européen
et je pense que c'est un travail CER que
la nation peut faire mais enfin
incontestablement que les engagements
internationaux de la France et elle peut
être en premier en premier point peut
l'apporter troisièmement je pense en
effet que si on veut des des critères
qui soient efficaces il faut évidemment
qu'il soit au minimum à l'échelle d'un
continent parce que même l'Australie qui
comme le chacun sa est un continent ilî
ne connaît pas les mêmes difficultés que
nous et donc nous pourrions tout à fait
nous enrichir de ce que fera la France
peut-être parère de réflexion quete un
certain nombre d'associations que
portent aussi des gens qui sont à Lofi
ou à l'ofpr il réfléch chisse à ça et je
pense qu'avec à la fois la jurisprudence
de la CNDA et la réflexion qui peut
porter notre projet de loi on pourrait
porter cette action international donc
moi aussi je me range à l'avis de
monsieur le rapporteur même si je veux
bien avouer que les questions autour de
manière plus précise du réchauffement
climatique concerne tant les débats
qu'il y a eu au Sénat qu'à l'Assemblée
nationale on en parlera sans doute dans
l'émicycle alors madame interme puis
monsieur de courourson
oui
très très rapidement pour dire que h
incontestablement il nous faut examiner
les questions externes qui font que la
question migratoire se pose chez nous
moi je trouve qu'effectivement
l'amendement de la commission est
intéressant mais je le trouve un peu
désincarné et je pense qu'on pourrait
rapprocher cet amendement de celui de
Monsieur Lucas qui parle du
réchauffement climatique qui est un
problème qui est devant nous et de
l'inscrire dans ce dispositif et je
pense que pour la séance on pourrait
utilement me semble-t-il mixer euh
l'amendement de la commission
aftr avec celui de Monsieur Lucas ou de
monsieur porte qui évoque la question
des du réchauffement climatique qui me
paraît tout à fait devoir être cité dans
un dans un tel
débat bon monsieur de courourçon oui
c'est un très bon amendement je
suggéreraai simplement un
sous-amendement c'est de supprimer le
mot
notamment parce que il ne trouve pas sa
place euh euh il pourudrait dire une
évaluation de la dimension externe des
migration et des causes structurelles et
pas notamment par que notamment on verra
on verra probablement ça en
séance déposé un sousamendement monsieur
le
Président il est sur
lois non c'est
pas pouvez déposer en séance si vous
madame
jeevard
alors non non attendez laissez la parole
à madame jeunvard je suis interrogative
sur le propos de Monsieur le Ministre
qui semble ouvrir la voix la
reconnaissance du de la notion de
réfugié climatique quand on voit dans
l'amendement de de Monsieur Lucas les
chiffres qui sont donnés dans l'exposé
des motifs ce sont des chiffres
absolument considérables et on le
comprend puisque ça concerne des
populations entières et donc est-ce que
la question que je me pose est de savoir
si finalement nul ne peut ignorer que
c'est un une évolution à venir mais
est-ce qu'on ne se donne pas bonne
conscience en adoptant cet amendement
tout en sachant qu'on ne sera jamais en
capacité d'accueillir aussi massivement
que le phénomène le demanderait des
réfugiés climatiques autrement dit
Monsieur le Ministre quand vous dites la
CEDH pourrait utilement revoir sa sa
doctrine en la matière et çaà dire que
vous ouvrez la voie la porte vers la
reconnaissance des de la notion de
réfugié
climatique d'abord dire Madame jeunev
que c'est dans notre pays parmi les
premers concernés NouvelleCalédonie 70 %
des g des personnes habitent sur le
trait de côte et seront concerné dans
les 30 ans qui viennent non mais je vous
donne un exemple de déplacement de
population voilà ou la Polynésie
française donc on a des sujets
évidemment qui touche à commencer par
notre propre pays deuxièmement il vaut
mieux que nous définissions dans les
traités internationaux des critères qui
permetttront jugés que de laisser à mon
avis la CNDA faire sa propre
jurisprudence ça me paraît plus efficace
pour le droit et pour l'accueil parce
que si nous si nous définissons pas des
critères nous de déplacement de
population de proximité d'accueil et
pourquoi pas de dédommagement on va
laisser faire les juges qui eux vont
avoir une à mon avis une construction
assez large de C qu'est-ce qu'un réfugié
climatique ce qui font déjà je rappelle
encore une nouvelle fois que si la
première demande d'asile est
l'Afghanistan la deème demand demande
d'asile avec la deuxième tau de
protection c'est le bagadesh pour lequel
les raisons politiques n'apparaissent
pas évidentes et donc je pense qu'il
vaut mieux qu'on définisse nous-même des
critères on a un débat politique sur
c'est quoi ces critères internationaux
et c'est une construction puisque seul
l'Australie l'a fait plutôt que de
laisser le juge le
faire bien donc je mets au voix
l'amendement 266 qui vote pour qui vote
attendez qui vote pour levez bien la
main parce que sinon je voilà qui vote
contre il il est adopt vous votez pour
ou contre alors je recommence le 266 qui
vote pour la main qui vote contre il est
adopté il fait tomber les autres le
501 bien nous interrogeons au travers
donc de cet amendement cl
501 la notion de pays sûr et
souhaiterions que cette notion de pays
sûr soit soit en quelque sorte
démocratisé par exemple d'un point de
vue démocratique et du point de vue de
la réalité de l'État de droit cette
affaire n'est pas
mineure dans dans la mesure où à partir
de cette notion selon laquelle un
certain nombre de pays seraient des pays
sûrs alors les ressortissants qui font
une demande d'asile voient leur
procédure accéléré et leur droit amoindr
on a bien compris que l'asile était en
soit une
politique et qu'en creux elle permettait
de caractériser les pays dont sont
ressortissant ce à qui on l'offre on
vous propose de se départir de ça et
d'objectiver la notion de pays sûr mon
le rapporteur ça tape vite
hein je croyais que vous parliez de la
vie que j'avais donné mais qui qui sera
qui ne sera effectivement pas
favorablefvorable la liste des des pays
d'origine sûre elle n'est pas établie
par le pouvoir politique
absolument pas en France elle est
établie par l'OFPRA et d'ailleurs quand
l'OFPRA établit une liste il peut y
avoir des recours vous savez que la
Siman avait fait un recours pour
contester la liste des pays d'origine
sur le Conseil d'État a retiré un
certain nombre de pays de la liste des
posos notamment le Sénégal parce que il
y avait des risques importants de
discrimination à l'égard des LGBT en
particulier et donc évidemment la liste
est composée en tenant compte de la
situation démocratique et des
caractéristiqu propres à chaque État de
droit notamment et notamment de la
question des libertés publiqu donc avis
défavorable car satisfait on
vérifiera je le mets au voix qui vare
pour contre
rejeté le 523 monsieur housoussin oui
merci monsieur le Président euh cet
amendement vise à connaître en fait le
taux d'activité des étrangers arrivé en
France au ditre du regroupement familial
c'est ardit en fait dans la population
de ces étrangers qui est est en âge de
travailler quel est le taux des
personnes qui travaillent ou qui sont au
chômage après avoir
cotisé
défavorable madame Chatelin
oui merci monsieur le Président on
a on on a une certaine obsession pour le
regroupement familial dans le discours
du rassemblement national comme si en
fait c'éit une espèce de man il y a
plein de gens qui arrivaient pour
profiter du système il faut rappeler
qu'aujourd'hui le regroupement familial
c'est entre 12000 et 14000 personnes par
an qui arrive c'est ça en fait les
chiffres que quand on regarde la la
présentation du professeur François
erand on voit que la migration familiale
n'est pour rien dans la hausse de
délivrance des titres de séjour
puisqu'en gros quand on regarde
l'ensemble des des chiffres sur la
migration familiale celle-ci recule de 3
% depuis 2005 donc je pense qu'il serait
de bonne àoi de retirer cette amendement
qui est juste la traduction d'une
obsession sans fondement du
rassemblement
national monsieur
Loman merci monsieur le Président je
trouve ça tout à fait étonnant cette
manière de de systématiquement cibler le
rassemblement le le le regroupement
familial excusez-moi excusez-moi le
regroupement
familial le ministre de l'intérieur
parce que parce que qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que le regroupement qu'est-ce
que le regroupement familial c'est
simplement la possibilité qui est donnée
à des gens qui sont dans une situation
régulière de se rassembler parce qu'ils
s'iment c'est ça le regroupement
familial c'est vous avez quelqu'un avec
qui vous êtes soit marié soit vous avez
un enfant soit vous avez un membre de
votre famille avec lequel vous voulez
vous regrouper j'ai dit rassembler mais
le mot était était correct aussi parce
que vous vous aimez qu'est-ce que vous
avez contre l'amour à la fin pourquoi
vous êtes systématiquement contre
l'amour pourquoi vous avez l'impression
que la haine ça serait toujours quelque
chose de favorable en fait vous devriez
vous appeler RN mais finalement la
deuxième lettre c'est aussi ce que vous
faites la haine alors je mets au voix
qui vote pour qui vote
contre il est rejeté madame leg grip le
1370 oui merci monsieur le Président
cette amendement de notre collègue
Lionel
wubert vise à introduire dans le Rapp
ort qui sera remis par le Gouvernement
au Parlement une évaluation des moyens
financiers humains des bureaux du droit
des étrangers au sein euh des des
préfectures hein nous le savons ça a
déjà été abordé euh les les délais
rencontrés sont souvent très longs les
difficultés engendrés peuvent être réels
et donc nous souhaitions pouvoir avoir
un un éclairage sur la la réalité et
donc l'évaluation réelle des moyens mis
à disposition des préfectures pour le le
traitement des demandes de titres de
renouvellement et cetera je vous remerci
monsieur le rapporteur oui nous avons
adopté il y a il y a quelques heurs un
amendement quasiment identique de Sarah
tanzili qui venz d'ailleurs recouper une
partie de l'amendement de Cécile
huntermer euh raison pour laquelle je
vous demanderai de bien vouloir le
retirer merci à vous madame le grip il
est retiré monsieur le rapporteur
général monsieur Gouffier Valante
ou merci Monsieur le le président euh
cet amendement du groupe Renaissance
vise à introduire une évaluation des
bénéfices de l'immigration en matière
économique sociale dans le rapport qui
sera remis au Parlement et qui pourrait
nous servir pour l'organisation des
débats en 2019 déjà un rapport sur
l'impact de l'immigration sur le marché
du travail les finances publiques et la
croissance de France stratégie présentai
les principales tendances de
l'immigration en France à sorti de
comparaison internationale ainsi qu'une
revue concernant l'impact de
l'immigration respectivement sur le
marché du travail sur les finances
publiques et la croissance rapport qui
reconnaissait les effets positifs de
l'immigration sur la croissance par an
et nous considérons qu'une telle
évaluation de ces aspects économiques et
sociaux serait nécessaire pour mesurer
pleinement les apports de l'immigration
à notre pays dans la construction de ce
rapport je vous remercie monsieur le
rapporteur oui favorable à à cet
amendement qui redonne un peu de hauteur
au futur rapport qui sera déposé devant
le le Parlement puisqu'il consiste à
insister sur les apports les
enrichissement pour notre pays des
migrations favorable monsieur
merci monsieur le Président moi j'ai
juste une question j'aurais voulu savoir
exactement quelle est la méthode de
calcul en fin de compte parce que et
quel type d'immigration on prend si on
prend ceux qui avec quel titre
exactement ils sont en France si c'est
des des migrants
irréguliers mais avec titres sans sans
titre et dans ces cas-là comment on le
comment on le calcule moi j'entends
l'amendement à la limite je trouve que
c'est intéressant de le savoir et ça va
dans la suite des différents amendements
qui ont été déposés pour avoir toujours
plus de précision donc moi je j'y suis
plutôt très favorable parce que ça nous
permet d'avoir des informations
supplémentaires mais si vous pourriez
nous éclairer sur ce qui va ce qui va ce
que va comporter cette cette évaluation
et comment est-ce que ça va être calculé
merci bien je mets au voix qui vote
pour j'ai oublié madame reg pardon
pardon j'oubli madame ro merci monsieur
le Président quand
même je trouve cet amendement de nos
collègues très intéressant et qui
permettrait peut-être de mettre à jour
les données parce que des données en
fait qui vont dans le sens de ce que
souligne votre amendement il y en a
d'autres il y a depuis la grande étude
de l'île 3 en
2009 et l'audit de l'Assemblée nationale
en 2011 la démonstration que si
l'immigration coûte autour de 45 47
milliards il en rapporterait 60 milliard
c'estàd beaucoup plus mais également
l'étude de l'OCDE en 2014 qui rappelle
que chaque personne rapporte et pour
répondre à mes collègues de Lyot peu
importe que ce soit des
immigrés qui ont des papiers ou qui n'en
ont pas encore puisque la TVA par
exemple tout le monde la paye que des
impôts on est amené à en payer quoi
qu'il en soit et que par exemple le
travail effectué rapporte à l'ensemble
de la société bref évidemment
l'immigration nous rapporte à toutes et
tous bien qui vote pour qui vote contre
rejeté adopté pardon adopté adopté c'est
bon madame CALV CIT
là non le 350
351 il a été retiré tout à l'heure avant
la séance le
1325 madame madame legrip ou madame
yadan madad oui je vous remercie
monsieur le le président cet amendement
de notre collègue Mathieu Lefèvre
concerne la procédure d'admission au
séjour pour soins et vise à compléter le
contenu du rapport remis chaque année au
Parlement par l'OFI et ce rapport
enseigne aujourd'hui le Parlement sur
les demandes reçues par l'OFI sur les
avir rendus par le service médical de
cet établissement et sur les données
générales en matière de santé publique
recueilli dans ce cadre en revanche ce
document ne comporte aucun élément sur
les suites données par l'autorité
administrative aux avis rendus par le
service médical de l'OFI si le Parlement
est informé de manière exhaustive sur le
nombre la nature et les caractéristiques
des demandes d'admission au séjour pour
soins il ne connaît en revanche pas la
suite réservée à ces demandes le nombre
de titres de séjour accordés sur le
fondement de l'article
l425-9 n'est ainsi pas connu tout comme
les données générales en matière de
santé publique recueillies dans ce cadre
l'amendement propose de remédier à cette
situation cependant compte tenu des
développements informatiques nécessaires
il propose que ces dispositions entrent
en vigueur seulement le 1er juin 2026
ainsi le ministère de l'Intérieur et
Lofi disposerait de 2 ans pour préparer
les transferts d'informations requis
monsieur rapporteur oui en effet le
rapport de l'OFI là je réponds aussi
àambord qui m'interrogéit il y a
quelques heures sur l'intérêt de mettre
le rapport de l'OFI dans dans le rapport
lui-même le rapport de l'OFI ne comporte
pas les données qui vientent d'être
mentionné par notre collègue député
Caroline yadan raison pour laquelle je
donne un avis
favorable bien je mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est adopté le
336 madame
Diaz merci monsieur le Président donc
toujours dans l'objectif d'enrichir ce
rapport qui serait présenté
annuellement nous nous souhaitons donner
la parole à tous les acteurs tous ceux
qui sont en contact avec des personnes
issues la d'immigration ou alors avec
des politiques en matière d'immigration
c'est la raison pour laquelle il nous
trouve nous paraît pertinent d'intégrer
les observations de la police aux
frontières pourquoi parce que ils ont
une vision globale et éclairée ce sont
des forces de l'ordes qui sont en
première ligne dans la lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine et les réseaux
de passeur et donc leur retour
d'expérience en matière de contrôle aux
frontières de lutte contre l'immigration
régulière irrégulière ainsi que de la
gestion des centres de rétention
administrative nous paraît pertinent
pour pour tendre vers un rapport
éclairé on pvez continuer parce queon a
les suivants qui sont également ce de
votre groupe donc le 342 le 391 393 395
443 alors moi je vais juste défendre le
342 si vous le permettez et bien pareil
la direction nationale de la sécurité
publique bien ce sont des agents des
fonctionnaires qui sont en première
ligne en ce qui concerne la lutte contre
l'immigration ce sont eux qui luttent
contre la délinquence ce sont eux qui
viennent au secours cours des victimes
de violences commises dans les
transports en commun et c'est la raison
pour laquelle leur avis nous paraît
pertinent et nous souhaitons qu'il soit
intégré au
rapport le 391
oui merci président cet amendement
déposé en commission des affaires
étrangères par mon collègue Michel
Guignot entend faire valoir l'importance
d'informer le Parlement de la part
d'étranger parmi les prisonniers des
établissements français en 2022 un peu
plus de 18000 détenus sur les 72000
prisonniers français étaient étrangers
au Pr 1 juillet de cette année-là la
population carcérale comportait donc 25
% d'étrangers la surpopulation carcérale
légitime cette demande d'information les
places de prison opérationnell en France
sont limité on dénombre un peu plus de
60000 places opérationnelles en prison
le dénombrement permettrait notamment
d'émettre quelques prétention de retour
près des pays dont dépendent ces
personnes incarcérées par ailleurs cet
amendement entend dénombrer la part
d'étrangers incarcérés en France notre
pays compte selon l'INC 5,3 millions de
personnes étrangères soit 7,8 % de la
population totale connaître la part
d'étranger dans les prisons permettra
d'évaluer la part d'étranger incarcéré
par rapport à la population étrangère
totale en France de manière à adapter
notre législation selon les résultats
obtenus tant sur la politique
d'immigration que sur la politique
pénale je vous remercie merci le 393
vous l'avez défendu aussi non le taux de
chômage en France est renseigné suivant
le sexe la tranche d'âge comme
laformation au 3e trimestre 2023 le sens
du Bureau international du Travail le
taux de chômage représentait 7,4 % de la
population active en France la la part
d'étrangers parmi cette population au
chômage reste néanmoins inconnu alors
même que les personnes bénéficiant d'une
carte de séjour en courte validité ou
d'une carte de séjour plurannuel portant
la mention salarié peut s'inscrire au
chômage le le contexte est pourtant à
l'inflation pour ce même 3è trimestre
2023 le nombre de chôeurs augmenté de
64000 pour atteindre 2,3 millions de
personnes en 2020 le palais
d'immigration noté que le taux de
chômage des immigré lors hors Union
européenne se levait à 18,4 %. cette
part considérable mérite d'être connu et
présenté de manière transparente à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est le sens de
cet amendement qui prévoit d'intégré au
rapport annuel les observations
émanantes du ministère du travail afin
d'informer le Parlement de la part des
personnes étrangères dans les
statistiques du chômage en France je
vous remercie qui défend le 395 madame
bord vous pouvez les deux à la suite ou
oui merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement de notre collègue hamelette
vise à permettre au Parlement de
disposer d'informations fiables sur les
évolutions du niveau de français parmi
les étrangers admis au séjour en France
sachant que il s'agit là d'un facteur
clé pour leur intégration cet amendement
s'appuie sur les statistiques de l'OFI
qui pour l'année 2022 révèle que 47,5 %
des signataires du contrat d'intégration
républicaine sont orientés vers une
action de formation linguistique ce qui
nous semble beaucoup trop peu compte
tenu du choix du niveau de français
retenu pour délivrer une dispense de
formation il s'agit en effet du niveau
A1 du cadre européen c'est-à-dire le
niveau le plus
faible le suivant madame obono j'ai
monsieur le Président ben non vous avezu
pardon alors le 443 voilà vous m'avez
dit les deux alors oui non mais je
prends les deux mais pas c'est pas les
mêmes voilà donc effectivement cet
amendement prévoit d'intégrer aux
annexes du rapport annuel des
observations émanant du ministère de
l'Intérieur et des outresmes afin
d'informer le Parlement de la
représentation de la population
étrangère disposant d'un titre de séjour
dans les statistique de la délinquence
et de la criminalité en France cette
information permettra à la
représentation nationale
au même titre que les observations de
l'OFI ou de l'OFPRA d'avoir un visuel
exa sur le sur le lien entre insécurité
et immigration et d'en connaître les
proportions euh madame donc le 504
pardon madame
AUO merci on va changer radicalement si
je puis dire de registre puisque nous
proposons de joindre euh à ce rapport
qui serait présenté devant l'Assemblée
nationale un un point de vue qui serait
celle de la Défenseur des droits un
rapport qui émanerait de ces services
dans la mesure où un/art euh des
réclamations sont portées par des
personnes étrangères et concernent leurs
droits fondamentaux deux éléments en
particulier émergent de de de de ce car
de remarque à la fois les questions de
dématérialisation et évidemment les
questions de délais délais qui on le
redit recré eux-mêmes des des S papiers
et cré évidemment de l'absence de
recours au droit en 11 secondes en 10
secondes en 9 secondes j'aurais bien
aimé évoquer avec vous c'est c'estes
lieu dit de mise à l'abri sur lequel
nous attendons toujours des réponses de
la part de Monsieur Darmanin qui sont
des lieux où les personnes sont retenues
sans droit ni titre un jour vous nous
répondrez non mais pour aller dans le
même sens que ma collègue Martin là nous
proposons d'intégrer les rapports du
Contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté et à l'inverse des
amendements qui ont pu être portés par
certains de nos collègues du rassem
nationale c'est une un retour
d'expérience du terrain qu'on peut vous
faire je sais qu'énormément de députés
de la majorité de l'anupes sont allés
visiter les centres de rétention
administrative à titre individuel j'en
ai visité h bientôt neuf à travers tout
le pays dont deux fois 20 scèes et sans
ces rapports nous ne pouvons pas avoir
la réalité de la maltraitance qu'on peut
trouvé hein qui est institutionnalisé
dans ces centres de rétention et je
pense particulièrement à celui de Vincen
et mini hamlo qui sont deux gros points
de focale et avant qu'on puisse réduire
le nombre de cras dans ce pays même si
vous avez succombé aux sirènes de
Monsieur soioti lors de la lopmie je
pense qu'il est important de pouvoir
intégrer ce rapport parce que la
Contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté c'est le CGLPL
c'est une de nos instances qui est le
plus intéressante pour pouvoir avoir
cette ce thermomètre à chaud de l'état
de nos
merci Monsieur Lua le
suivant merci monsieur le Président
alors c'est un amendement qui vise à ce
que les les remarques du haut
commomissariat au réfugiés puissent être
intégré dans le rapport remis
annuellement au Parlement et en fait ces
remarques du Haut Commissariat aux
réfugiés seraient extrêmement importante
pour être vraiment certain et certaine
que nous respections les droits humains
qui sont quand même à la base de la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme que
nous avons nous-mêmes écrit
ensuite sur les sur le les rapports et
le pourcentage les statistiques de
chômeurs de nationalité étrangère et
cetera et bien moi je vous proposerai
aussi qu'on intègre au bout d'un moment
des statistiques ethniques qui nous
permettraient de voir que en génération
+ 1 c'est-à-dire les enfants de toutes
ces personnesl sont non seulement
parfaitement intégrés qu'elles ont des
diplômes qu'elles travaillent et que
finalement et bien la France aura été
une chance pour ses
familles et enfin le
326 madame
legrip merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement de notre collègue Mathie
Lefèvre vise à confier à l'opérateur
France travail le soin de fournir dans
le rapport annuel qui sera transmis par
le Gouvernement au Parlement des
observations et des données relatives à
l'intégration professionnelle des
étrangers en effet le code du travail
prévoit que les autorisations de travail
accordé aux étrangers sont délivré par
l'autorité ministrative lorsque la
demande remplit notamment une condition
de publication non satisfaite d'une
offre d'emploi pendant un délai de de 3
semaines il y a un nombre de données de
Statistiques qui pourrai être utilement
porté à la connaissance du Parlement sur
la nature de ces offres d'emploi le
répartition géographique l'issue de ces
demandes de manière à avoir une
appréciation plus fine de la réalité de
l'intégration professionnel des
étrangers dans notre pays
merci Monsieur rapporteur et une une
réponse globale à ces très nombreux
amendements euh il est demandé euh
l'observation d'un certain nombre de
direction d'administration publique la
direction nationale par exemple de la
police aux frontières la direction
nationale de la sécurité publique elle
relève de du ministère de l'intérieur
par conséquent du gouvernement elles
seront consultées lorsque le
gouvernement devra présenter euh son
rapport et donc il n'y a pas besoin de
les consulter par observation qui
figurit en propre dans euh le rapport la
même euh remarque vaut au fond pour la
volonté de faire en sorte que les
observations du ministère du Travail du
MAE du ministère de l'Intérieur bien sûr
soit intégré le gouvernement diffusera
un rapport qui lui appartient et qui
vient en appui des orientations qu'il
proposera sous forme d'objectifs
chiffrés et indicatifs concernant
l'immigration donc pour cette raison
avis défavorable pour celles et ceux qui
propose Défenseur des droits Contrôleur
général des lieux de privation de
liberté la question n'est pas de
l'intérêt de ces observations évidemment
et d'ailleurs je ne doute pas un seul
instant que le moment venu le Défenseur
des droits fera part de ces observations
comme nous l'avons nous-même auditionné
mais nous ne pouvons pas demander à une
autorité administrative indépendante
nous ne pouvons pas demander à une
autorité administrative indépendante de
diffuser ses observation dans le rapport
du gouvernement ce serait contraire à
leur statut pour cette raison
défavorable à l'ensemble des
amendements je précise qu' on entend
annuellement les Aï comme la Défenseur
des droits ou la contrleur général des
lieu de privation de liberté madame
jeunevard alors attendez je c'est bon
c'est bon je vous l'ai
rendu merci monsieur le président de
cette longue discussion commune je
retiendrai deux éléments qui me
paraissent intéressants tout d'abord
l'amendement de de Madame Diaz qui
préconise qu'on intègre dans ce rapport
la direction nationale de la police aux
frontières je pense qu'il y a beaucoup
d'enseignements à tirer des observations
de la la PAF que le ministre de tutelle
n'ignore pas naturellement mais qui
serait utilement porté à la connaissance
du Parlement je pense en particulier à
la
dématérialisation qui selon les dires de
la police sans frontière occasionne
beaucoup de fraude de fraude
documentaire qu'il est très difficile de
vérifier donc je c'est une des
observations que nous pourrions dont
nous pourrions être destinataire et la
deuxième remarque que je trouve tout à
fait intéressante c'est la suggestion de
Madame Rousseau qui est de de de de
valider le principe de statistique
ethnique alors voilà qui est tout à fait
surprenant mais j souscris parce que je
crois qu'on na jamais à craindre de la
réalité madame
Martin il nous a répondu sur les sujets
précédents qu'après tout nous
auditionnons
une fois par an la Défenseur des droits
et la et la représentante donc des des
lieux de privation de liberté la
contrôleur ça ne nous satisfait pas et
du coup nous en profitons pour reposer
la question quel est le statut de ces
lieux de mise à l'abri que moi j'ai pu
visiter donc à Menton ce sont des lieux
qui sont intégrés au locaux de la PAF
que d'ailleurs je crois vous voulez
agrandir en terme de nombre de personnes
à recevoir en tout cas c'est ce que j'ai
lu monsieur Darmanin et que donc vous
nous indiquez quel est le statut de ces
lieux dans lesquels on retient femmes
enfants majeurs mineurs bref tout ce qui
passe en attendant que la frontière
italienne soit sur un plan administratif
ouverte vous nous devez une réponse
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur donc
nous l'attendons puisque vous ne la
donnez pas par écrit donc nous
l'attendons ici devant la commission des
lois je mets donc au voix successivement
les amendements le 336 pour contre re
le 342 pour contre rejeté le 391 pour
contre rejeté le 393 pour contre rejeté
le 395
pour contre rejeté 443 pour contre
rejeté
504 pour contre
le 545 pour contre rejeté le 1100
pour contre rejeté le et enfin le 1326
pour contre
rejeté alors on envent à une série
identique suivante le
493 très bien merci monsieur le
Président nous souhaitons donc par cet
amendement supprimer l'alinéa 28 qui
correspond en fait à un serpent de mer
qui fait plaisir donc notamment à la
droite sénatoriale qui nous l'a rajouté
dans dans un texte déjà bien bien lourd
et bien bien grave et qui en fait
illustre euh à la fois l'inutilité et
surtout l'incongruité totale de de tout
ce texte de loi parce que d'abord cette
politique elle a été testée c'est la
politique d'immigration choisie cher à à
Sarkozi sur laquelle euh il serait bon
de faire effectivement des des bilans
avant de de reproduire ça à l'infini on
pourra en discuter plus tard sur les
textes sur sur le travail mais en plus
ça engloberait tout un ensemble de
procédures d'admission comme par exemple
le regroupement familial pour lesquels
il ne peut être question de de quota
puisque ça ne doit pas être une variable
et euh donc de notre point de vue ce cet
alinéa doit être supprimé parce que il
est il va à l'encontre des droits
principaux et fondamentaux de personnes4
Monsieur Solignac merci monsieur le
Président je m'empresse de dire que les
quotas ou les objectif chiffré c'est la
même chose pas le même vocabulaire mais
c'est exactement la même chose c'est
dangereux ça sert à rien si ce n'est à
démontrer qu' en réalité en la matière
aucun objectif chiffré n'est possible
parce que l'immigration est liée à un
certain nombre d'aléas dont on a
d'ailleurs largement parlé et qui
rendent évidemment tout ça absolument
impossible à chiffrer c'est surtout
inopérant les quotas c'est en général un
désordre important et c'est même le
président de la République lui-même qui
le dit puisqu'il a dit que les quotas
n'étaient pas réalistes et qu'on ne
saurait pas les tenir je je rappelle
également la commission présidée par
Pierre Mazo en 2009 et c'est c'est assez
c'est assez drôle de savoir qu'à
l'époque Pierre Mao avait dit que les
quotas pouvaient créer un appel d'air
pour satisfaire les contingents fixés
par par les pouvoirs publics donc ceux
qui prétendent vouloir se prémunir des
appels d'air en réalité risquent de les
créer en voulant créer ces quotas ou ces
objectifs chiffrés donc c'était
évidemment de notre part une suppression
de cette alinéa 28 le 1380 monsieur
sainthuile il est pas là il est le seul
signataire oui ok le 1419 alors qui le
signe euh est-ce qu'on a un représentant
madame
bereté merci euh monsieur le Président
donc je vous présente un un amendement
qui était proposé par Madame Dupont et
un certain nombre de députés Renaissance
donc l'instauration de quotas en matière
de politique migratoire n'est ni
souhaitable ni concrètement réalisable
elle ne permettra pas de répondre
concrètement aux besoins de notre pays
et c'est illusoir d'identifier à
l'avance le nombre d'étudiants qui
auront par exemple la possibilité de
venir en France ou encore le nombre de
proches et d'ailleurs euh nous avons
parlé de tous ces exemples d'ailleurs
européens il y a quelques heures de cela
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
proposons donc de supprimer la mise en
place des quotas en matière
d'immigration alors il me reste monsieur
gilet pour le 418 oui monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues alors que 80 % des Français
réclament que l'on prenne des décisions
fermes en matière d'immigration que 73 %
considère que la politique migratoire
française est trop laxiste et enfin que
63 % des Français sont inquiets pour
leur sécurité l'alinéa 28 de ce projet
de loi n'est qu'un faux semblant qui
vise à faire croire à nos compatriotes
que par l'étab des quotas le
gouvernement agit et a conscience de la
situation migratoire en réalité il n'en
est rien pire encore l'alinéa en
question prévoit que le Parlement
détermine pour les années à venir le
nombre d'étrangers admis à s'installer
durablement en France pour chacune des
catégories de ses jours à l'exception de
l'asile cette détermination du nombre
d'étrangers admis à s'installer
durablement sur le territoire français
s'inscrit dans le cadre d'une politique
favorable à l'immigration bref cette
mesure va à l'encontre de ce que nous
souhaitons nous au rassemblement
national et de ce ce que souhaite par
pardon les Français qui peut croire
qu'instaurer des quotas reviendrait à
limiter l'immigration alors même que
l'Assemblée nationale est composée de
partis de gauche du centre et d'une
prétendue droite qui ont tous été au
pouvoir et qui sont tous responsables de
l'immigration massive voilà pourquoi je
monsieur le rapporteur j'avoue j'ai pas
bien compris la la toute dernière
intervention peut-être des
contradictions avec une une intervention
précédente d'ailleurs et puis surtout je
je ouis je si je crois que vous avez
défendu les quotas il y a quelques
heures il me semble mais on regardera
avec attention le contendu pour pouvoir
vous le redire en en séance et je ne
voudrais pas prendre la Commission à
témoin mais il me semble que vous avez
dit exactement le contraire il y a
quelques heures mais enfin c'est c'est
pas très grave il y a eu beaucoup
d'inexactitude dans nos débats depuis
déjà plusieurs
heures la politique des quotas ça la
politique des quotas ça n'est pas celle
que nous voulons et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons
amendé l'article 1ier a une première
fois et je leis fit d'ailleurs on appuie
un amendement de Monsieur Castellani
dans quelques dans quelques minutes nous
souhaitons que le gouvernement
définissent ses orientations nous
souhaitons que ces orientations
s'appuient sur un rapport nous sommes
d'accord en cela avec le Sénat avec tous
les éléments que nous avons y compris
ajouté au cours de notre discussion nous
souhaitons que le gouvernement Vienne
devant le Parlement en indiquant des
objectifs chiffrés des objectif
forcément indicatif pourquoi indicatif
parce que que fait-on au 100
étranger qui ne se verrait pas accorder
un titre de séjour parce qu'il y aurait
un plafond chiffré et définitif que
fait-on de cette personne quelle est la
procédure juridictionnelle à laquelle
l'État devra faire face par exemple et
donc il y a là une impossibilité qui est
presque j'allais dire matérielle en
revanche contrairement à ce que notre
collègue Solignac a dit il y a quelques
instants il y a des domaines migratoire
sur lesquels nous pouvons agir et de
façon tout à fait maîtrisée c'est le cas
pour les visas étudiants
a une possibilité pour l'état de décider
combien il veut et quels sont ses
objectifs en terme de visa étudiant il n
d'ailleurs aucune contrariété de nature
constitutionnelle ou conventionnelle
pour le faire de la même façon pour
l'immigration économique et c'est
d'ailleurs au fond déjà le cas car
l'ensemble des titres de séjour que nous
délivrons au terme du travail au terme
l'action économique le sont sur la base
de critères qui sont totalement
maîtrisés en revanche il y a un interdit
absolu c'est l'asile bien sûr et sur le
regroupement familial il ne peut pas y
avoir de d'objectif qui soi plafonné
parce que il y a là aussi des
engagements conventionnels donc d'une
certaine façon il y a partage
d'expression avec ce qui a pu être dit
par une partie de nos collègues il y a
quelques instants en revanche ce qui est
absolument impossible je l'ai signalé
dès ma première intervention concernant
le sujet des de la politique de
l'article 1er ea pardon c'est
l'impossibilité pour le Parlement de
déterminer ces objectifs chiffr ce n'est
pas une compétence qui relève du
Parlement il faudrait pour cela réviser
l'article 34 de la Constitution et donc
je vous proposerai dans quelques
instants non pas de de réviser la
Constitution nous aurons l'occasion je
rassure monsieur banalisis d' discuter
le le 7 décembre avec la PPL
constitutionnel DLR mais nous devons
modifier l'article alinéa 28 pour que le
Parlement simplement débatt
présente et pas déterminé ça ne sert pas
à rien c'est la Constitution mon cher
collègue alors il y a un débat sur la
modification de la Constitution nous
pouvons l'avir nous sommes à droit
constant c'est le vote d'un loi
ordinaire et par conséquent je vous
proposerai dans quelques instants en
appui de l'amendement de notre collègue
castelliani de clarifier ce qui au terme
du texte du Sénat était tout simplement
impossible sur le plan constitutionnel
et conventionnel monsieur banan
oui je je sur le rassemblement national
là je comprends pas votre amendement
parce parce que bon non mais c'est c'est
c'est pas pas très logique tout à
l'heure vous étiez à défendre l'idée de
de de cota donc alors peut-être que vous
faites peut-être que vous faites la
veœux en réalité que cota ou pas de
toute façon ce qui vous ce qui vous
choque vous c'est l'idée de l'étranger
c'est c'est peut-être la révélation de
ça en réalité et que même si que même si
notre pays a des besoin j'aime pas ce
mot mais c'est une réalité de de main
d'œuvre étrangère le fait qu'elle soit
étrangère vous iris de toute façon donc
peut-être c'est pour ça que vous avez
cet amendement qui qui veut supprimer
les quotas le le mot enfin la question
des quotas elle est très délicate et et
moi je je suis très dubitatif sur ce
terme par contre que nous ayons une
politique migratoire définie avec un
certain nombre d'objectifs et un certain
nombre de une certain nombre de réponse
à des réalités économiques et a des
réalités humaines humaines quand c'est
le regroupement familial et économie
quand nous avons
besoin on pense par exemple merci ah oui
c'est une minute madame
Genevard il
m'a merci merci monsieur le Président je
voudrais réagir au propos de notre
rapporteur
général vous avez modifié l'alinéa 2 et
vous vous vous vous apprêtez à modifier
l'alinéa 28 de cet article qui sont les
deux alinéas un peu clés et
si je je vous
rejoins sur le fait de pouvoir établir
des quotas par exemple pour les
étudiants je demande à voir si vous irez
au bout de cette intention ou de cette
possibilité en tout cas vous avez vous
avez confirmé qu'il était possible
d'établir des quotas pour les étudiants
c'est bien ce que vous avez dit des
objectifs chiffré de même pour
l'immigration
économique de même pour l'immigration
économique ce qui est intéressant parce
que ça préfigure le débat que nous
aurons pour le CAD bis je vous rejoins
lorsque vous dites monsieur le
rapporteur général qu'il est impossible
en l'état du droit et puis puis par
rapport à ce qu'est l'asile d'établir
des objectifs chiffrés pour l'asile en
revanche sur le regroupement familial et
ce sera l'objet d'une prochaine
discussion je pense que là il y a
matière à discuter merci il y a matière
à discuter parce que l'article 8 de la
cdH euh n'est pas n'est pas un totem
absolu monsieur
gilet monsieur
gilet oui monsieur le Président
rapidement premier point monsieur
Balanant je sais pas où est-ce que vous
êtes allé chercher cette histoire que
nous défendrions les quotas parce que
jamais nous ne les avons défendus pour
une raison très simple pour une raison
très simple c'est que définir des quotas
c'est juste une manière pour ceux qui
sont au pouvoir de faire semblant de
sortir les gros bras alors même qu'ils
font tout l'inverse ensuite et là c'est
pire encore on nous parle donc de ne pas
définir des des quotas nous
parlementaire mais vous vous voulez
carrément que les quotas soient définis
par le gouvernement et que les députés
ne servent à rien une fois encore vous
méprisez la représentation nationale
vous représ vous méprisez pardon les
représentants du peuple que nous sommes
alors si ça ne dérange pas certains
d'être des députés moutons excusez-nous
nous ça nous dérange je sais bien que
monsieur balanan lui ça lui convient
bien
c'est un rôle qui maîtrise parfaitement
mais nous on ne l'accepte pas c'est au
peuple de décider de sa politique
migratoire point barre et certainement
pas à des gens qui ne sont pas élus et
qui sont membres du gouvernement
Monsieur Merci monsieur le Président ce
qui est intéressant c'est de voir la
forme d'unanimité qu'il y a par rapport
pour supprimer l'an 28 et en fait de
remettre en cause le principe même qui
fonde l'article 1a car débat que nous
vons d'avoir de vouloir ajouter des
éléments dans le rapport se fonde
exclusivement sur cette idée venue du
Sénat d'établir ses quotas et j'entends
le discours de dire des objectifs
chiffrés des objectifs chiffrés
excusez-moi chers collègues ça s'appelle
des quotas donc moi ce que je propose
aux collègues de la macronie c'est tout
simplement de réfléchir à supprimer
cettea et d'arriver à l'article 1B qui
sera beaucoup plus intéressant et
beaucoup plus utile pour notre travail
parce que en réalité et vous l'avez dit
toutes les informations que nous avons
demandé avec des rapport avec des
augmentations avec des argumentaires
diverses et variés on peut les obtenir
soit chez les chercheurs et j'aimerais
bien qu'on remette un peu le primat de
la recherche avant le primat du
politique de temps en temps dans not
travail dans notre travail et donc
supprimons cette an et passons au 1B
madame Rousseau
oui la suppression de cette alinéa est
en jeu parce que en fait la question de
la politique du chiffre c'est que à
partir du moment où on rentre là-dedans
ben il y a plus de politique humaine
possible en fait puisque tout répond à
des chiffres et à des objectifs chiffrés
et en l'occurrence là il y a enfin moi
j'ai j'ai l'impression quand même qu'il
y a eu une évolution du discours dans
cette commission puisque au début de au
début de l'après-midi on discuter de
faire des quotas par pays enfin et que
ça serve la politique diplomatique par
pays puis là tout à coup on se dit que
finalement ben non on va pas faire de
quotas et en fait c'est mieux qu'on
aille pas dans les chiffres parce que
précisément le que la politique
migratoire c'est avant tout l'h la sur
laelle nous travaillons c'est avant tout
de l'humain donc abandonnons les
chiffres supprimons l'alinée 28 et tout
ira mieux monsieur Gouffier
Val juste monsieur le
Président vous dire que je suis outré
par les propos que nous venons
d'entendre et le qualificatif de mouton
adressé à une partie des collègues ici
notamment notre collègue herwan balanan
qui je le dit est un parlementaire qui
devrait qui doit et qui je pense nous
inspire chacune et chacun dans les
prises de position
qu'il peut avoir en faisant un vrai
travail de fond en exprimant la position
qui est la sienne y compris sur des
sujets qui sont qui sont complexes et le
jour où l'on verra des députés eren par
moment s'affranchir de la ligne
directrice du polite bureau je pense que
nous aurons ce jour n'est pas n'est pas
arrivé en tout cas mais ces propos sont
je pense
auieux tout simplement AB et moi je
tiens au nom du groupe Renaissance à
apporter tout notre soutien au collègue
er ban et enfin
[Musique]
madamemeer très bien non moi très
rapidement sur l'article 28 et reprenant
finalement les propos de mon collègue
Solignac mais aussi celui du président
de la République qui considérait que les
cotas n'était pas réalistes et ne on ne
saurait pas les tenir moi je suis très
interrogative par rapport à une
disposition qui vise à mettre en place
des obj
sans qu'on nous dise comment on va les
tenir parce que il me semble que c'est
au législateur de vérifier aussi la
façon dont ces quotas seront
comptabilisés et mis en ligne ça c'est
un le rôle du législateur donc de toute
évidence le dispositif n'est pas n'est
pas à
maturité monsieur le ministre avant que
nous faisions un vote parce que un
public puisque j'étaé saisi par écrit
par plus d'un diè de la
Commission
mercisieur ministre merci monsieur le
Président je pense qu'on a déjà eu en
partie cette conversation tout à l'heure
mais peut-être que vous n'étiez pas là
monsieur le député mais votre collègue
du rassemblement national a défendu avec
vigur les cotas qui lui répondre que
Madame mélonie elle-même faisait euh des
cotas je sais pas si vous vous en
rappelez d'augmentation justement et
donc vous vous avez à la fois défendu
rassemblée nationale mais la Commission
et les contreendu en feront fois à la
fois les cotas obligatoires parce que
c'était l'objet de notre discussion tout
à l'heure et aujourd'hui la suppression
des quotas tout courts vous avez réussi
à vous contredire dans la même dans la
même séance ce qui est pas mal c'est
qu'il y av la pause dîné entre tempemps
peut-être dire à Madame jeunevard que
elle a je crois bien compris les propos
du rapporteur général et peut-être les
miens tout à l'heure c'estàdire que ce
que nous proposons y compris amendé par
le rapporteur général c'est en effet des
quotas des objectifs chiffré qui
permettent d'être en effet indicatif
comme vous l'avez très bien dit ne
peuvent pas être prescriptifs pour des
raisons que l'on connaît constitutionnel
mais pas simplement mais qui permet
surtout je pense que ça c'est très
intéressant à partir du moment où le
gouvernement justifie chaque année de sa
politique migratoire et les objectifs
d'être puré annuel je pense que la
grande plusvalue qu'apporte le Sénat et
sur lequel on souscrit c'est le fait
qu'on présente des objectifs chiffrés
sur 3 ans et à chaque fois de pouvoir
les les moduler un peu lorsqu'on fait
des prévisions économiques on les
présente sur plusieurs années c'est tout
à fait
évidemment important puisque l'essentiel
de ces quotas c'est soit des quotas
étudiants soit des quotas économiques
sur l'asile vous l'avez dit vous-même ça
se heurte non seulement à la CEDH mais
également à la la déclaration de droit
dehomme et du citoyens et et au préembul
de 46 on aura le débat sans doute sur la
PPL constitutionnelle mais même
l'immigration familiale c'est pas très
évident d'imaginer que on puisse écraser
comme vous l'imaginez dans la PPL
constitutionnel puisque bien sûr il y a
la CEDH qui pourrait tout à fait écrasé
on pourrait partir de ce principe par
une modification du peuple souverain sur
ou ses représentant sur la constitution
mais l'alinéa 10 de la déclaration du
préambule de 46 pardon prévoit la vie
privée familiale avant même de souscrire
la cdH il y a déjà le préambule des 46
qui est intérieur à la cdH et Don
le le Conseil constitutionnel a depuis
longtemps considéré qu'il faisait partie
de notre État de droit et notre bloc de
constitutionnalité donc la modification
constitutionnelle n'empêche pas les
jurisprudence future du Conseil
constitutionnel qui s'appuie sur la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et le
préambule de 46 reparlera évidemment le
le le le 7 décembre donc pour vous dire
que les quotas ou les objectifs chiffrés
indicatif qui permet chaque année un
débat au Parlement sur 3 ans et en effet
sur les deux motifs essentiels de
l'immigration en France que sont les
visas étudiants et les visas
économiques bien donc je vais appeler
chacun vos noms vous me direz
distinctement si vous êtes pour contre
ou abstention madame Caroline
Abad monsieur
monsieur romain BRI madame Fanta bereté
cont madame Fanta
beré pour l'amendement de suppression
contre l'amendement de suppression
abstention monsieur Hugo
bernalicis madame Pascal
bord monsieur Yan
Boucard monsieur Florent bouier
contre madame Blandine Breard Monsieur
Michel Castellani
contre madame Émilie
Chandler est-ce que vous pouvez vous
taire que je puisse entendre les
collègues s'il vous
plaît madame Clara
chagol pardon
contre Monsieur pour ouais c'est
bien elle a dit pour
monsieurti Monsieur jean-fançois coul
mad j madame é
diz madame Elsa
fossillon madame Raquel garido madame
Annie
jeunevard
contre Monsieur Johan
gilet Monsieur Philippe gos monsieur
Guillaume gouff
Valente madame Marie
guevennou madame Claire
Guichard monsieur Jordan
Guiton monsieur sachaouer est contre
Monsieur Timothé
housoussin madame éod
Laforge madameid monsieur Mansour
camardine madame
Mar monsieur
handicrat Monsieur Philippe latombe
monsieur Gill
lejandre madame constance
legrip Monsieur Antoine léomand madame
Marie
lebeec madame Marie France
l monsieur Benjamin
Monsieur Emmanuel Mandon Monsieur
Laurent
marangé madamea
Martin Monsieur Thomas ménager madame
emmanu Ménard monsieur Ludovic mendz
madame la
Miller madame mchou madame Dani
Obon monsieur é
po Monsieur Emmanuel
porinés monsieur pardon Madame Michelle
Peron contre Monsieur Thomas
porte madame Mar pouss vinbac Monsieur
Philippe Pradal monsieur aélien Pradier
monsieur Stéphane Ramb monsieurot
madame monsieur
davanadame Béatrice
rou madameine Rous
monsieurignac Monsieur R berger monsieur
philipperek Monsieur Olivier serv madame
saranz
madamesieur
monsieur Boris
Vallo C pardon monsieur Boris
vallotomp monsieur Guillaume vilt
monsieur Jean-Luc varsman madame
carolineadan j'ai 25 contre
23 reconte on va faire sur
ex
alors bah on va recom on va on va
recommencer parce que on est on a pas
des comptes alors on recommence non non
il faut faut
qu'on je recommence ass debout non mais
je recommence B attendez moi j'ai mes
comptes à moi ça donne contre on a les
comptes mais on a pas les mêmes décomtes
donc de toute façon c'est compes mais on
n pas les mêmes déctes donc comme c'est
public il nous faut un décompte et donc
je recommence donc ce sera sera contre
c'était sûr moi j'avais le décompte ici
mais puisque vous voulez un décompte
précis on va l'avoir on recommence va
trop vite par contre comme vous parlez
tous en même temps je peux pas tous
entendre on
recomencecoup peut-on voter dans le
micro allez madame Caroline
Abad monsieur
Balanant contre Monsieur romain B absent
F
pour Monsieur HUG
Bernal madame Pascale bord monsieur Bou
n'est pas là Monsieur FL Bou
cont BL
bre Monsieur Michel Castellani
contre madamem
Chand madame CLA
ch monsieur monsieur jean-fçis cou mail
Jon m Diaz madame Elsa
fossillon madame Rael garido madame
Annie
jeunevard monsieur Johann
Gillet Monsieur Philippe goselin
monsieur Guillaume Gouffier
Valente madame Marie guevou madame
Claire Guichard contre Monsieur Jordan
Guiton monsieur sachlier contre Monsieur
Timothé housoussin pour Madame Elodie
jaqu
Laforge madame Émeline carbidi monsieur
Mansour camardine madame Marie tar
monsieur handic Brat pour Monsieur
Philippe latombe contre Monsieur Gill
Legendre madame conence legrip Monsieur
Antoine
léoman madame Marie
lebeecre madame Marie France
ler monsieur Benjamin Lucas Monsieur
Emmanuel Mandon Monsieur Laurent
marcangé madameisa
Martin Monsieur Thomas ménager
madameemmanuard monsieur Ludovic mendz
contre madame Laur Miller contre madame
Ney mchou
contre madame Daniel auonau pour
monsieur Éric
pooget Monsieur Emmanuel pèin contre
madame Michel Peron
contre Monsieur Thomas
porte madame marieè pouss vincebac
contre Monsieur Philippe Pradal
contre monsieur rien Pradier monsieur
Stéphane rambau monsieur ri rberotte
madame SRA regol
pour Monsieur David riman madame
Béatrice Roulot pour Madame sine
Rousseau monsieur HERV
Solignac monsieur Raphael Chen berger
Monsieur Philippe Schrek Monsieur
Olivier serva madame SAR
tanzili madame André
torgha monsieur
jeanterlier madame
cécileuntermeilleer monsieur Boris
valallot
et monsieur Guillaume V et Madame
carolinead donc nous avons bien 29 voix
contre 24
VO
contord
ce qui pour exactement à notre décompte
mais bon le suivant monsieur Hadad vous
pouvez défendre l'amendement de la
commission des affaires europé
étrangères pardon merci monsieur le
Président dans la continuité du débat
que nous venons d'avoir la commission
des Affaires étrangère propose de
remplacer la la question des quotas par
des objectifs et des résultats chiffrés
qui seraient présentés tous les ans par
le le gouvernement sur une période de de
de 3 ans ce qui permettrait en effet de
garder une logique d'objectif de de
transparence de contrôle du Parlement
sur la politique migratoire bien sûr à
l'exception de l'asile quand ça a été
mentionné par le rapporteur général et
et par le ministre les cotas POS en eff
faet un problème d'égalité devant le
droit et un problème de mise en œuvre
pratique mais en revanche cette question
des des objectifs et des résultats
chiffrés nous nous paraît être un un bon
compromis pour avancer sur ce sujet
merci
alors Monsieur Michel
Castellani mer merci Président nous
restons dans le même fil donc notre
amendement réécrit un peu le cette
alinéa 28 en proposant une rédaction
alternative qui nous semble plus
équilibrée avec la fixation par le
Parlement d'objectif chiffré d'objectif
chiffrés du nombre d'étrangers admis au
au au séjour c'est une rédaction qui
nous semble plus réaliste et qui ne qui
ne contrevient pas au double principe de
à la fois du d'humanité et de et de
réalisme qui devrait présider selon nous
à la rédaction de de cette loi
merci alors monsieur le rapporteur vous
avez un
sous-amendement je vais essayer de
d'expliquer la la totalité des
amendements des positions sur ces
amendement euh il s'agit donc de
modifier la première phrase de l'alinéa
28 qui est la suivante le Parlement
détermine pour les 3 années à venir et
cetera j'ai indiqué il à plusieurs
reprises que pour accepter
cette expression alors il faudrait
modifier l'article 34 de la Constitution
ça c'est un autre débat il ne nous
revient pas de de le faire les deux
amendements que nous avons à la fois de
la commission des affaires étrangères et
de Monsieur Castellani vise à modifier
cette phrase le Gouvernement présente
chaque année au Parlement pour les trois
avenirs qui là est tout à fait conformes
à nos engagements constitutionnels il y
a une petite différence mais qui est
majeure entre l'amendement 268 de la
commission des affaires étrangères et
l'amendement 598 c'est que l'amendement
268 oublie de préserver la réserve de
l'expression l'objectif en matière
d'immigration familiale établi dans le
respect des principes qui s'attache à ce
droit c'est-à-dire à la fois nos
engagements conventionnels et le
ministre de l'Intérieur l'a rappelé il y
a quelques instants nos engagements au
titre du préambul de la Constitution de
1946 qui fait partie de notre bloc de
constitutionnalité au quel cas je
préfère en effet donner un avis
favorable au 598 de Monsieur Castellani
je souhaite en revanche y apporter des
précisions de deux natures d'abord de
préciser les titres qui son serit
concerné par ces objectifs chiffrés et
donc vous le constatez il y a une
énumération qui est très claire et qui
notamment écarte la possibilité de
l'appliquer à l'asile notamment et
d'ajouter Infiné que le gouvernement
devra indiquer lorsqu'il présentera ses
objectifs dans une logique par ailleurs
pluriannuelle d'indiquer les raisons qui
expliquent les écarts observés entre les
objectifs fixés et les résultats
réellement enregistré ce qui est une
façon d'éclairer la représentation
nationale d'objectiver le débat sur la
base je le rappelle des objectifs des
orientations qui seront défendu alors
par le gouvernement donc avis
défavorable au
268 favorable au 598 sous-amendé par
l'amendement que je porte moi-même
monsieur Valot le sous-amendement
suivant oui une occasion de d'expression
pour commenter le sous-amendement de
notre rapporteur général rappelez
d'abord que cet article cet amendement
n'était pas dans le projet initial il
était parfaitement inutile à l'équilibre
que magnifique que vous considériez que
le gouvernement avait trouvé en réalité
quel est votre rôle monsieur le
rapporteur général si ce n'est que
d'agiter des hochets au nez de la droite
donc il fa bien conserver quelques voies
pour espérer éventuellement avoir une
majorité des objectifs chiffrés vous
pourrez tourner le terme dans tous les
sens et user à nouveau de méthode de
jésuite mais c'est des objectifs à
atteindre ou à ne pas
dépasser et il faut ensuite expliciter
les raisons de l'écart à l'objectif du
gouvernement c'est-à-dire éventuellement
prendre des des mesures correctives pour
atteindre ces objectifs qui sont des
objectifs de politique publique ce sont
donc bien des quotas je dois dire que au
moment où je vous parle je me range à la
vie qui était celle du président de la
commission des lois qui à propos des
quotas et on pourrait dire la même chose
des objectifs chiffré puisqu'ils sont de
même nature ça c'est plus qu'une ligne
rouge c'est inutile et bien oui c'est
plus qu'une ligne rouge c'est inutile la
réalité c'est que au fond vous avez
décidé de participer après le Sénat du
durcissement du projet original et à
toute force de continuer de faire bien
maladroitement du en même temps voilà on
en est on en est là évidemment j'appelle
à ne pas soutenir l'AM monsieur de
Courson vous leviez la main pour
présenter l'amendement
ou non alors c'est Monsieur Castellani
qui défend l'amendement suivant alors
jela le
594 si si je voulais préciser à mon
collègue ah non non c'est pas pour
défendre l'amendement le
594 non non donc on
défendend4 cell et faire un petit rappel
historique de ce que
disait on défend l'amendement 594 donc
c'est votre collègue Castellani qui a la
parole bon oui merci Président nous
suggérons que à la première phase de la
de la l 28 au mot asile on ajoute séjour
pour motif
familial cette exclusion nous nous
semble nécessaire puisque la rédaction
actuelle de cet article est contraire à
l'article 8 de la Convention européenne
des droits de l'homme qui garantit le
droit au respect de la vie privée et
familiale donc pour nous il ne sera à
rien de voter un texte qui ne sera pas
applicable j'ajoute que le meilleur
moyen pour contrôler l'immigration
familiale est de fixer des critères
strictes
des clair pour tout le monde voilà c'est
donc de bonnes politiqu notre
amendement monsieur neigelen le suivant
595 merci merci monsieur le Président
alors je comprends pas exactement
pourquoi ils ont été mis en en
discussion commune mais le but de cet
amendement est est simplement d'ajouter
à la Linéa à 28 les mots et des
capacités d'accueil de de la nation
c'est uniquement pour s'assurer que les
limites qui seront fixé par le Parlement
plutôt ses ses objectifs en terme en
terme d'accueil soit fondé sur des
critères qui sont des critères réalistes
et prendre aussi en compte nos capacités
réelles d'accueil on a eu l'occasion
d'en d'en parler tout à l'heure sur ce
qui est aujourd'hui faisable et que ce
ne soit pas au détriment d'autres
populations donc c'est le sens de cet
amendement et le le la la le complément
sur l'alinéa
28 et enfin le 1025 monsieur Lucas oui
monsieur le Président la la politique
des quôas elle est inepte et cet
amendement il est un forme de de de de
cri du cœur si je puis dire pour que on
arrête de compter dans les chiffres de
l'immigration les étudiants si je devais
résumer la situation des étudiants
étrangers je pourrais dire quatre rir
repartent rapportent réussissent
rayonnent repartent parce que
l'essentiel des étudiants en fait
aspirent à à repartir dans leur pays
c'est une fierté pour la France de les
accueillir qu'ils partent ou qu'il
restent d'ailleurs il rapportent j'ai
dit tout à l'heure même avec vos
arguments purement utilitariste purement
comptable je fais appel là à à à
l'argument qui pourrait vous vous
convaincre moi qui ne me parle pas
énormément mais 1,35 milliards d'euros
euh par an ils réussissent plus que les
autres parce qu'il faut avoir beaucoup
de volonté pour venir de loin étudier
dans notre pays et il rayonne il
contribue au rayonnement de la France et
et à son image et à son influence à
travers le monde de ce point de vue-là
vouloir et vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure j'étais très choqué parce que
vous avez dit monsieur le rapporteur
général en disant on va pouvoir mettre
des quotas sur les sur les étudiants la
France devrait se battre pour s'enrichir
les étudiants étrangers plutôt que de
les mettre dehors mon monsieur le
rapporteur général non monsieur Lucas je
n'ai pas dit que l'on pouvait mettre des
quotas sur les visas étudiants j'ai dit
qu'il y avait deux catégories de titres
qui sont à la maîtrise de l'exécutif
plus que l'immigration familiale qui
dépend d'autres circonstances encore
plus évidemment que la demande d'asile
ce sont les visas étudiants étranger et
c'est l'ensemble de ce qui relève de
l'migration économique je n'ai pas dit
que nous allons appliquer les quotas
j'ai même expliqué tout à l'heure que si
nous devions avoir des plafonds chiffrés
c'est ça des quotas alors que
faisons-nous lorsque le plafond à
l'unité prês ETP j'ai été extrêmement
clair sur ce point tout à l'heure et
donc je suis en conformité complète avec
l'expression qu' pu avoir monsieur le
Président de la Commission des loi au
cours des dernières semaines vous avez
essayé de nous opposer c'est inutile sur
l'amendement 594 de Monsieur Castellani
juste que l'on se comprenne bien la la
réserve de comment dire qui consiste à
ne pas toucher au regroupement familial
et déjà présente à l'AL 28 et donc il
est inutile de l'ajouter le motif
familial figure à l' ligée 28 c'est la
dernière phrase et c'est la raison pour
laquelle mon cher collègue j'ai préféré
votre amendement 598 tout à l'heure au
268 de la commission des affaires
étrangères parce que la commission des
affaires étrangères ne rappelit pas la
nécessité de respecter le regroupement
familial qui ne peut pas en effet faire
l'objet ni de quotas ni d'objectif
chiffrés et donc pour cette raison
défavorable en revanche favorable à
l'amendement de notre collègue
Christophe nagelen parce que c'est une
évidence en effet l'objectif de capacité
d'accueil de la nation et bien il doit
évidemment être mentionné et affirmé
c'est une nécessité évidente et
républicaine et l'amendement 1025 de
notre collègue Lucas je lui ai répondu à
quelques instants donc
défavorable alors monsieur de Courson
cette fois-ci c'est votre moment vous
aviez bon alors madame
fossillon je je je vois bien les
discussions qui consistent à faire comme
si au travers de de cet amendement nous
tournions le dos vous tourniez le dos à
la politique des
quotas je je crois que ce n'est pas la
réalité et qu'ici vous faites preuve
d'une forme de de relâchement coupable
qu'au fur et à mesure en tentant de de
jouer faussement l'équilibre vous
finissez par valider de très vieilles
revendications autour de la préférence
nationale d'ailleurs quand les cotas ont
été mis en place en France je pense dans
dans les années 30 elles l'ont été au
nom de la préférence nationale et nous
avons vu aussi à cette époque je je je
dans l'histoire il y a par exemple des
des étudiants de médecine qui manifester
pour la mise en place de quotas pour
éviter par exemple que des médecins
juifs puissent exercer et ça ça s'est
produit en France la politique des quôas
en réalité elle a son histoire et à
force de valider
thè monsieur
léoman bon et ben voilà on y est on se
rend compte du bazar idéologique qui
existe chez vous vous savez plus ce que
vous défendez ce que vous défendez pas
et en réalité vous êtes en train de
défendre des choses en pensant au fait
qu'il va vous falloir l'appui des
républicains pour pouvoir avoir le vote
du texte et donc vous faites n'importe
quoi tout à l'heure on avait un vote sur
les quotas alors voilà on votait sur
l'AM l'alinéa 28 sur les quotas
c'était c'est pareil dans la macronie il
y en avait certains qui étaient pour les
quotas d'autres qui étaient contre les
quotas mais ce qui m'a intéressé c'est
que du côté du MoDem ils étaient pour
les quotas alors que tout à l'heure ils
ont défendu un amendement dans lequel il
était écrit l'application de quotas
trienaux pour chaque catégorie de séjour
ne semble pas pertinente alors moi je
comprends plus rien vous êtes pour ou
vous êtes contre les quotas parce que un
coup vous votez pour un coup vous votter
contre et tout ça vous le faites non pas
en fonction de ce qui est bon pour
l'intérêt général et pour l'intérêt de
notre pays mais pour ce ce qui est bon
pour pouvoir faire passer votre texte
avec la avec l'appui des républicains
pour faire à la fin des trucs qui sont
des palcopies du rassemblement national
monsieur
ménager merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues en
fait on vient de vivre quelque chose de
très grave en fait il y a il y a
l'article 27 de la Constitution qui
interdit des mandats impératifs en fait
qui dit que le vote doit être personnel
or on se rend compte aujourd'hui ce soir
que certains députés ont déposé des
amendements et ont voté contre leurs
propres amendements sous la pression de
la macronie sous la pression d'un groupe
quand on voit bien que le V va être
assez assez serré donc en fait on se
rend compte que c'est pas des moutons
mais c'est des Playmobil à qui on dit de
lever la main en fonction en fonction
des intérêts du gouvernement des
intérêts de la macronie et moi je les
invite les chers collègues macronistes à
défendre les intérêts des Français qui
attendre une diminution très ferme de
l'immigration et pas de défendre les
intérêts d'une caste d'un groupe et de
défendre vraiment les Français donc déjà
dans tous les cas vous avez un mandat
qui doit être un mandat représentatif et
non un mandat impératif donc c'est très
grave parce que vous venez par votre
comportement au final de baffouer notre
Constitution monsieur monsieur ménager
d'abord quand il y a 5 voix d'écart sur
54 exprimé ça veut dire que grosso modo
l'écart il est significatif et ensuite a
priori ce ne sont pas les collègues de
la majorité qui ont été empêchés par
leur groupe de déposer des amendement
monsieur
Solignac merci monsieur le Président on
est on est dans un numéro d'hypocrisie
absolument totale et qui va pas durer
très long longtemps parce que les
Français ne sont pas dupes quota c'est
pas beau c'est sale on prend pas mais
objectif chiffré c'est propre ça passe
c'est rigoureusement la même chose par
définition un objectif chiffré c'est une
cible à atteindre et monsieur le
rapporteur général vous dites vous-même
dans votre sous-amendement que vous
voulez observer les écarts entre les
objectifs chiffrés et les résultats
enregistrés mais pourquoi faire observer
des écarts si c'est si ça n'est pas pour
le réduire cet écart et démontrer que le
gouvernement a atteint les objectifs
chiffrés qu'il avait lui-même gravé dans
le marbre donc on est là dans dans un
numéro totalement hypocrite et je vais
même vous dire vous avez besoin de faire
croire que on peut réguler et c'est tout
simplement une opération de
communication en direction du Sénat mais
vous allez vous prendre les pieds dans
le tapis parce que vous mettez en route
une mécanique infernale infernale qui va
vous obliger à fixer des chiffres toute
l'Europe va nous regarder avec cette
histoire là à fixer des
chiffres vous allez atteindre les
résultat oui merci monsieur le Président
juste pour rassurer monsieur léomand je
vous rappelle que nous avions un
amendement de suppression sur l'ensemble
de de ce dispositif oui excusez-moi je
vous interromps pendant votre séance
twitch donc premier point deème point
nous sommes contre les quotas nous avons
voté contre un amendement mais nous
sommes contre les quotas faut faut
suivre c'est c'est assez simple et pour
vous rassurer complètement le groupe
s'abstiendra sur cet article en
cohérence en cohérence avec
Ben à partir du moment où nous nous nous
proposons un amendement de suppression
au départ et ben nous ne sommes pas
satisfaits de l'arrivée de cette article
et nous nous abstiendrons donc voyez
nous sommes complètement
cohérents alors j'ai encore madame
jeunevard monsieur Lucas et
ensuite un amends S oui je vais essayer
monsieur le Président de parler merci
j'aimerais bien que vous puissiez
réussir madame jeunevar j'ai j'ai un
voisin un peu un peu bruyant
j'ai 50 voisins bruillants madame jeev
monsieur monsieur le Président moi je
voudrais revenir au sous-amendement du
rapporteur général je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup
d'hypocrisie en fait de côas il n'y en a
plus il n'y en a plus parce que vous lui
avez
substitué la notion d'objectif ind
et que ces objectifs indicatifs ne font
pas obstacle à la délivrance de visa et
de titre par conséquent il y a pas
d'objectif il y a plus de
Cotard
non madame vous c'est terminé bon
monsieur
Lucas merci Monsieur le le président
voilà ce que nous avions dit avant
l'examen de ce texte confirme n'ayant
pas de majorité la fameuse aile gauche
du camp présidentiel ayant cédé toutes
les digues et renoncé à tous ces combats
nous voici dans le moment où vous avez
engagé monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur le rapporteur
général une surenchère une négociation
mortifère avec la droite radicalisée
avec l'extrême droite qui vous conduit
tout en maquillant la réalité en faisant
passer des vaisis pour des lanternes à
faire croire que ces quotas n'en sont
pas c'est extrêmement grave parce
qu'Emmanuel Macron a été élu et réélu
dans notre pays deux fois
sur uniquement la volonté de millions de
gens de faire barrage et d'empêcher
l'extrême droite d'accéder au pouvoir
dans notre pays et vous validez ces
thèmes ces termes ces thèses en cédant à
une vieille revendication qui consiste à
valider l'idée qu'il y aurait une
submersion migratoire parce que c'est ça
que dit ce débat sur les quotas donc je
vous invite encore une fois mes chers
collègues de la majorité minoritaire à
avoir quand même ce qu'il y a un peu
d'humaniste en vous qui se réveillent et
qui disent que maintenant ça suffit que
ce n'est pas possible que votre exercice
du pouvoir se termine ainsi en déroulant
un tapis rouge à l'extrême droite et à
la droite radicalisé en validant ce que
sont ces argumentaires depuis des
décennies et en allant plus loin même
que Nicolas Sarkozi et Briss sortefeu
rendez-vous compte rendez-vous compte
oui enfin si vous parlez tous en même
temps dans votre coin monsieur
Gouffier oui oui elle sera bien tenue
quand ce sera vous madame Martin sauf
que vous ne l'aurez jamais c'est dommage
monsieur Bouffier al difficile de
ramener un peu de raison dans ce débat
et quand je vous entends monsieur Lucas
aller plus loin c'est un texte quand on
voit le volet intégration sur l'accès au
cours de français quand on voit le volet
intégration sur la régularisation aux
mains et la responsabilité du salarié
quand on voit que nous allons passer
l'interdiction sur le plat dans les CR à
18 ans ce qui n'a jamais été porté
durant un gouvernement de gauche ou dans
des programmes des différents candidat
de gauche je pense qu'il faut ramener un
peu de raison sur la réalité de de ce
texte par ailleurs si pour je reprenais
tout àheure tout à l'heure les mots pour
reprendre les mots de de Boris valallot
sur le fait qu'il y aurait un
durcissement du texte euh parler de
durcissement du texte quand nous avons
déposé des amendements de suppression
qui sont conformes à à nos valeurs sur
ce qui a été introduit par les sénateurs
sur laame sur la nationalité sur les MNA
sur l'hébergement d'urgence sur les
prestations sociales je ne pense pas
qu'il s'agisse d'un de durcissement par
contre oui nous avons dit dès le départ
que nous étions prêts à la discussion
sur un certain nombre de points dont cet
article 1a à partir du moment où nous
allions le réorienter vers la
construction d'un débat construit à
partir d'un rapport qui oui aurait des
données objectivées euh bien entendu et
euh et
circonstancié monsieur le
ministre bien merci beaucoup monsieur le
président prident j'ai j'ai un peu du
mal à comprendre le débat à cette heure
un peu tardif pour essayer peut-être de
de remettre un certain nombre de
perspectiv dans ce que nous faisons
depuis le début depuis le début de ce
texte dans le texte initial du
gouvernement dans le texte initial du
gouvernement il n'y avait pas non mais
il n'y avait pas de quotas ou d'objectif
chiffrés il est tout à fait vrai que
c'est un ajout de la majorité
sénatoriale l'ajout de majorité
sénatoriale correspond correspond aux
engagements du Président de la
République qu' a évoqué en janvier 2019
je vous renvoie ces déclarations qui
d'ailleurs sont si vous tapez les choses
sur votre ordinateur votre téléphone
vous y trouverez facilement les
déclaration du Président de la
République puis en novembre 2019 lors
d'un comité interministériel à
l'immigration puisque mon prédécesseur
Christof castader ont été le Ministre en
charge qui prévoyait à la fois une
cohérence avec ce qu'il a toujours
défendu peut pas y avoir et c'est ce que
nous disons tous depuis le début de ce
débat il ne peut pas y avoir dans le
cadre de la Constitution actuelle de
quotas prescriptif qui englobe l'asile
ou qui englobe l'immigration familiale
mais il peut avoir des objectifs
chiffrés des cotas vous les appelez
comme vous le souhaitez puisque ils sont
légèrement différents dans leur
acceptation juridique qui dit ce que
doit faire ou ce que veut faire le
gouvernement et en l'occurrence ce que
dit le Sénat ce que nous reprenons bien
volontiers sur plusieurs années alors ça
paraît comme ça original les quotas mais
c'est ce que font la plupart des pays
qui nous entourent la plupart des pays
européens qui soient socio-démocrate je
renvoie le Parti socialiste aux
excellents socialistes du Danemark par
exemple ils sont à l'international
socialiste ils sont ils sont
l'international socialiste vous n les
avez pas vous les avez pas encore exclus
vous les avez pas vous pas en exclus
voilà non mais la différence ne vous
inqu ne vous inquiétez pas la différence
avec eux c'est qu'ils sont ils sont au
pouvoir parce qu'ils ont pas nié la
question migratoire pour le peuple c'est
une grande grande différence avec vous
peut-être bon
et de l'autre côté et de l'autre côté
des gouvernements qu'on pourrait
qualifier de centriste ou de modéré ont
choisit les objectifs chiffrés et c'est
un peu fort de café que la LFI nous
explique que nous fionions le jeu de
l'extrême droite parisque vient de
défendre des arguments et les propos de
Madame Le Pen quielle a toujours défendu
qu'elle ne veut pas de Cotat migratoire
l'extrême droite a toujours été contre
donc nous dire qu'on singe l'extrême
droite sur les Cotat alors que toujours
été contre sauf au début de votre
commission non non mais sauf au début de
votre commission monsieur le député mais
vous avez mis un petit peu de temps à
vous vous avez mis un petit peu de temps
à vous rendre compte du programme de
Madame Le Pen c'est vrai que vous avez
peut-être été rappelé en effet à de
meilleures disposition par quelques
commissaires mais ce qui est certain
c'est qu'on ne pouvait pas nous faire ce
procès puisque c'est effectivement le
cas de la plupart des par des parlements
européens et occidentaux puisqu'on a
parlé du Canada également mettre les
objectif chiffré sur l'immigration de
travail économique ou sur les étudiants
c'est pas en soi dérangeant puisque ça
dépend de notre capacité d'accueil
capacité d'accueil dans les universités
capacité d'accueil dans le marché du
travail et on peut tout à fait imaginer
qu'on module les chiffres du
gouvernement si une crise économique
venait arriver et qu'on décidait que
malgré les engagements on décide de
faire moins et on le justifie devant le
Parlement ou de faire plus parce qu'on a
ici ou là une main d'œuvre qui manque
mais regardez les visas étudiants ce
qu'on ne dit pas dans les visas
étudiants c'est que l'une des
difficultés des visas étudiants et moi
je suis comme le rapporte général je
sais très bien que nous ayons un maximum
de visas étudiant par à partir au moment
où ces étudiants font leurs études en
France de façon réelle et sérieuse
c'estàd un apport qui a apporté le le
Sénat moi je suis pas je suis pas
favorable à la caution mais je suis
favorable à la condition de l'étude
réelle et sérieuse c'est qu'on sait tous
que launiversité publique fonctionne en
enregistrant des personnes qui se décare
étudiant et qui touche les subventions
publiques non pas par rapport au
concours ou à l'examen passé et par
rapport à l'inscription bah on le sait
tous c'est un débat budgétaire qui ne
qui n'en finit pas et donc il y a
évidemment quelques facultés qui
utilisent aussi cette arme d'inscription
étudiant la question c'est savoir si ça
correspond à de véritables parcours
d'études et à de véritables projets de
vie en France et c'est pas mal de
pouvoir le définir donc je je vois pas
ce qu'il y a de de de terrible à à une
politique que vise la plupart des pays
européens autour de nous qui soit
socio-démocrate qui soit socialiste ou
qui soit d' gouvernement modéré il n'a
jamais été la panage extrême droite sauf
au début de cette commission donc ce ce
combat n'a pas lieu d'être il est tout à
fait conforme à ce qu'a dit le président
de la République par deux fois en 2019 à
partir du moment où on n met ni l'asile
à partir moment ni pas l'immigration
familiale pour des raisons qui ont été
évoqué conventionnelles et
constitutionnelles et à partir du moment
où il n'est pas prescriptif et qui
permet simplement d'avoir un débat
chaque année devant le Parlement qui
explique ce que veut faire le
gouvernement est-ce que c'est une
réussite ou pas une réussite et là
effectivement on peut en débattre à
l'envie parce que quand on regarde les
les titres de séjour et je constate
monsieur le rapporteur général que
souvent cet argument nous est opposé
vous n'avez jamais autant donné titre de
séjour mais ça peut être voulu de la
part d'un gouvernement on peut être
contre on peut être pour mais ça peut
être vu c'est pas subi de donner des
titres de ces jours étudiant ou de
travail et ce sera encore plus vrai si
le gouvernement venait et vous déclinez
jusqu'à la fin du kaken combien par
exemple il voudrait faire de titre de
séjour pour en discuter avec les
branches professionnelles et ce serait
pas malance voi et si on les refuse
alors ces cas-là il faut accepter les
réformes d'assurance chômage ou de
formation que propose le gouvernement
par ailleurs donc ces objectifs chiffrés
sont à la fois conformes à ce que fait
le gouvernement depuis
2019 et par ailleurs à la à ce que font
la plupart des gouvernements
sociau-démocrates et centristes de
l'Union européenne
alors prix un par un le 268 qui vote
pour le
268 avis défavorable non non non d'abord
c'est les articles là le premier
amendement le 268 n'est pas sousamendé
c'est le suivant qui demandé non ça
c'est trop tard une foison a
commencé sur l'article moi B
alors qui vote contre le
268 il n'est pas adopté ensuite on en
vient au 598 le premier sous-amendement
celui du rapporteur qui vote
pour alors il y a 20 + 4 + 4 + 1 il y a
donc 29 voix qui votent contre
8 + 3 + 3 + 3 + 7 ce qui fait 14 + 12 26
29 contre 26 il est adopté
le amendement suivant
tombe et donc je mets au voix
l'amendement de Monsieur Castellani
sousamendé par le rapporteur qui vote
pour donc je compte également 29 voix
qui vote
contre votez pas donc 24 voix il est
adopté il fait tomber les suivants sur
le vote de l'article donc vous avez
voulu un scrutin
public est bien présent par contre il il
va pas être adopté
hein c'est parti alors on seit s'il vous
plaît madame Abad l'article pour
l'article
monsieur
Balan Monsieur B madame ber
pour Monsieur
Bernal Madame
B monsieur
Bouard Monsieur
bouier Madame Breard monsieur
Castellani madame
Chandler
pardon
m monsieur monsieur cou madame desjon
madame
Diaz madame
Fillon gar madame
je contre Monsieur
gilet monsieur goselin monsieur gouf
Val
madad pour
monsieur
Guiton monsieur
housoussin monsieur Jay Laforge Jay
Laforge
pardon pardon toutes mes
excuseson parle en même temps j'arrive
pas à faire les deux choses à la fois
madame carbidi monsieur camardine madame
Caram monsieur carb
contre Monsieur la
tombe vous pour monsieur tombe oui
monsieur le gend
attention euh madame leg
gripp Monsieur
léoman Madame le
becec madame
lurau monsieur Lucas
contre Monsieur Mandon
abstention monsieur marcangéi pour
madame
Martin monsieur
ménager madame Ménard Monsieur
mendz Madame
Miller madame
mchou madame
obono monsieur
poet Monsieur
péin Madame
Peron monsieur
porte madame poussier
vincebac monsieur Pradal pour Monsieur
Pradier monsieur Rambo Monsieur reberot
Madame rol contre Monsieur riman Madame
Roulot
abstention madame
Rousseau monsieur
Solignac euh monsieur chéen berger
monsieur Shrek monsieur serva madame
tanzili est pas là madame vous êtes là
madame
tanzili j'entends pas je suis
désolé madame
torinia monsieur Terlier madame unmer
monsieur
valallot monsieur
vilt monsieur versman
madamead 24 pour 17 contre 12
abstentions il est
adopté on passe à l'article 2 monsieur
le rapporteur votre amendement de
suppression prier B pardon prier ba même
vous mettez pas j'ai pas
oui merci monsieur le Président c'est
simplement que les dispositions ajouté
par le Sénat au à l'article 1er ba sont
déjà satisfaites puisque en réalité il
s'agit du
réacheminement des personnes qui
sont parvenues sur sur le territoire
national dans des conditions d'égalité
d'inégalité pardon d'illégalité je vais
y arriver et en
l'occurrence il est proposé à cet
article que si l'entreprise de transport
aérien ou maritime se trouve dans
l'impossibilité de réacheminer elle le
fasse ensuite sous le contrôle des
personnes de la de la frontière
compétente et en réalité c'est tout à
fait le cas c'est évidemment la la PAF
qui réachemine et lorsque la PAF ne peut
pas réacheminer parce que par exemple
l'entreprise de transport ne veut pas
avoir dans son propre avion si je prends
cet exemple des agents armés alors
l'état passe par ses propres moyens soit
en faisant appel à des prestataires soit
en faisant appel à sa propre flotte au
quel cas cet article est tout à fait
inutile raison pour laquelle je propose
de le de le supprimer j'ai fait la même
proposition avec les mêmes arguments
monsieur le rapporteur
madame monsieur balanan peut-être vous
être le deuxiè signataire ou madame ja
défendu pour les même raison défendu
madame fossillon vous êtes signataire du
suivant non alors attendez bougez pas
je
oui
attendez est-ce que CELI monsieur carbid
il
est il y a pas de signateire
présent le 1542 monsieur Gouffier
oui merci monsieur le Président
amendement de suppression pour les mêmes
raisons que le raorteur général au nom
du groupe Renaissance je vous imagine
favorable monsieur rapporteur par déposé
un amendement identique qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est adopté il
supprime l'article 1er
ba le
464 pour le le premier
bb qui le défend au groupe rassemblement
national oui monsieur le Président je
vais défendre l'amendement 46 de mon
collègue Kevin Feffer donc c'est un
amendement 1B donc pour supprimer cet
article la création de visas
francophones travailleurs et
entrepreneurs ouvert au pays membres de
l'Organisation internationale de la
Francophonie constituerait une nouvelle
source d'immigration pour des motifs
économiques alors que la France compte
228 million de demandeurs d'emploi et
que le taux de chômage est de 7,4 % au
3e trimestre 2023 je vous
remercie euh qui défend le suivant pour
le groupe
modem monsieur latombe
il est défendu monsieur le rapporteur
général
favorable je le mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est adopté et il
supprime l'article premier bébé après
l'article j'ai un amendement de Madame
Abadi le
1086 merci monsieur le Président euh la
demande de titre de séjour peut-être
particulièrement laborieuse quand par
exemple dans un département grand comme
l'iser le demandeur habitant à Vienne
doit se rendre plusieurs fois à la
préfecture de Grenoble 1h30 de voiture
pas de train pour compléter son dossier
on nous rapporte qu'il arrive
fréquemment qu'on apprenne au gré des
rendez-vous les pièces manquante alors
que l'article 114-5 du code des
relations entre le public et
l'administration indique que
l'administration recevant une demande
incomplète indique la liste exhaustive
des pièces manquantes cet amendement
vise donc à ce que cette liste
exhaustive lui soit transmise dès le
début de la procédure je vous remercie
monsieur le rapporteur général oui merci
monsieur le Président c'est un
amendement d'appel en tout cas je
l'interprète de cette façon ma cher
collègue Abadi parce qu'en en réalité
vous demandez à ce que soit inscrit dans
cette loi les dispositions du code des
relations entre le public et
l'administration qui existe donc par
conséquent et qui impose d'indiquer les
pièces manquante dans la situation que
vous avez signalé mais vous soullignez
un problème que nous avons abordé à
plusieurs reprises déjà depuis euh le
milieu de l'après-midi concernant le
traitement par les préfectures euh d'un
certain nombre de dossiers de titres de
séjour de renouvellement et sur ce point
il me semble que le ministre a apporté
ainsi que moi-même des éclairages et
pour cette raison euh une demande de
retrait à défaut défavorable
ouais monsieur bernalicis
oui je je me demandais si on avait déjà
parler de la nef parce que ça va pas
aider quand même l'Agence Nationale des
étrangers en France pour demander les
pièces manquantes parce que déjà que ça
fonctionne comme il est prévu que ça
fonctionne ce qui est pas gagner en la
circonstance et puis en plus bon bah
cont concrètement à d'autres types de
procédures on peut avoir des imprimés
traduits dans sa propre langue sur les
pièces manquantes et cetera l'agence
national des étrangers en France c'est
que français ou anglais hein voilà
français ou anglais après
débrouillez-vous si vous savez ni parler
français ni anglais surtout ne soyez pas
étranger he sinon vous allez avoir des
difficultés voilà donc je pense que
c'est un amendement d'appel intéressant
parce
que peut-être qu'il pointe du doigt le
fait que s'il y avait un accueil
physique possible dans toutes les
préfectures et sous-préfectures dans
tous les bureaux d'étrangers pour avoir
des réponses à ces questions peut-être
que ce serait plus simple mais pour ça
de toute façon il y a une proposition de
loi qui est examinée jeudi prochain en
séance publique sur sur le sujet voilà
vous invite à être présent je mets au
voit l'amendement de Madame Abad qui
vote
pour 3 4 5
6 qui vote contre
il est
adopté le
549 monsieur
porte monsieur oui cet amendement vous
propose de supprimer l'article qui
durcit les conditions du regroupement
familial pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut
s'opposer à cet article parce que les
conditions qui sont ajoutées propose par
exemple de de deos de repousser l'âge
pour pouvoir participer à ce ce
regroupement familial mais je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure qu'est-ce que l'idée du
regroupement familial qu'est-ce que ça
permet c'est le le le nom est clair ça
permet de regrouper des familles
normalement les gens de droite vous nous
bassinez sans arrêt avec la famille la
famille la famille et là quand il s'agit
de familles qui ont deux nationalités
différentes ou qui
ont la même nationalité et qui vivent
sur notre sol de manière légale alors là
vous aimez plus la famille pourquoi
expliquez-nous pourquoi exactement je
veux vous entendre pourquoi vous avez un
probl
avec la famille quand elle n'est pas
purement française c'est quoi exactement
le problème l'histoire de notre pays est
faite de famill qui se sont mélangé et
qui à la fin font des Français
magnifiques monsieur Valot le 851
oui amendement de suppression en se
fondant d'abord sur la réalité des
chiffres tels que notamment les appr du
François eran le regroupement familial
est stabilisé il n'augmente pas
contrairement à ce que peut prétendre la
droite et et l'extrême droite et les
conditions qui sont posé sont assez
indignes et et pose d'ailleurs parfois
des questions de sens quand on demande
de disposer d'une assurance maladie
alors que il s'agit de d'étrangers en
situation régulière qui sont affiliés à
la sécurité sociale on a du mal à en
comprendre le sens pas plus que le fait
de repousser l'âge à partir duquel il
pourrait avoir un regroupement familial
et puis on éudera d'autres amendements
sur les conditions de Lang qui sont tout
à fait savoureuses aussi et on imagine
ce que serait la réciprocité d'ailleurs
si elle devait advenir donc amendement
de
suppression le suivant qui le défend
pour le groupe écologiste monsieur Lucas
ah tu
faire re c'est M ch qui faire
merci monsieur le Président nous
déposons cette cet amendement de
suppression pour plusieurs raisons le
premier c'est que les depuis depuis plus
plusieurs à plusieurs reprises il y a eu
des tentatives d'interdiction du
regroupement familial et cela est
contraire au droit de vivre en famille
parce que ce qu'on ne dit pas c'est que
dans le parcours d'immigration c'est
aussi un parcours maillé de séparation
c'est-à-dire on se sépare on se sépare
de son compagnon s'accompagne de ses
enfants pendant parfois des années c'est
travailler dans un pays pendant que ces
enfants grandissent dans un autre et
donc en fait que oui notre Constitution
reconnaît le droit de vivre en famille
c'est un principe constitutionnel et
pour cette raison il n'a jamais été
heureusement possible d'interdire le
regroupement familial alors il y a des
contournements qui ont été utilisés
notamment par la droite et qui
continueent d'être c'est-à-dire qu'on
durcit les critères on les durcit
tellement que cela devient impossible et
donc avec cet amendement de suppression
on dit stop on dit effectivement qu'on
conformément à notre Constitution
conformément à nos valeurs aujourd'hui
une personne qui vit en France qui
construit sa parant sa vie en France a
le droit de faire venir sa famille pour
vivre avec
elle
madame Fillon je vérifie si vous êtes
signataire parce que vous NZ pas seul
oui oui merci Monsieur le le Président
nous nous opposons également à cet
article qui vise à durcir les conditions
du regroupement familial je crois que
celles et ceux aujourd'hui qui qui
cherche à limiter le le regroupement
familial savent en fait très très bien
qu'aujourd'hui il n'est qu'une part très
réduite des titres de séjours qu'il est
même plutôt en baisse mais il y a une
fixation tout à fait obsession
sur le regroupement familial parce qu'en
réalité il permet de de décliner tous
leurs ponif raciste il faut le dire
d'abord généralement vis-à-vis du nombre
d'enfants faits par les femmes venues de
l'étranger ça c'est le premier ponif
raciste mais aussi qui leur permet de
décliner aussi la théorie du du Grand
remplacement donc il ne faudrait pas que
ces personnes viennent s' inststaller
durablement et face des enfants en se
mélangeant à ceux et celles qui sont qui
ne sont pas issu de l'M igration voilà
pourquoi il y a une fixation
obsessionnelle alors même qu'ils savent
absolument qu'elle représente
aujourd'hui à peu près 12000 titre
annuel et qu'elle est en baisse depuis
quelques années monsieur
balanan en plus des des arguments qui
ont été donnés je rajouteraiis tout
simplement un
argument
conventionnel et
opérationnel constitutionnel je suis je
suis mais en tout cas conventionnel et
et opérationnel
euh effectivement d'ailleurs aussi
constitutionnel c'était un peu plus loin
dans ma note vous avez raison monsieur
valallot donc donc effectivement nous
allons nous nous avons proposer cet
amendement sur les questions de
d'exigence de de de niveau de français
c'est ça contrevient au dispositif de la
directective européenne du 25 novembre
202 2003 pardon relative au statut des
retor de pays-tiers résident de longue
durée idem pour l'Assurance Maladie
enfin c'est ça ne tient pas la route
donc nous allons demander la suppression
de cet
article monsieurint n'est pas là
ensuite
ber
Peron non défendu je défends aussi le
mien monsieur le
rapporteur
oui merci Monsieur le le Président c'est
un un article qui a été donc ajouté cela
a été précisé il y a quelques instants
par nos collègues sénateurs et qui
mérite que l'on soit précis dans
l'évaluation des éléments qui nous sont
proposés d'abord de quoi parle-t-on cela
a été dit à à plusieurs reprises nous
parlons de 14000 ressortissants de
nationalité étrangère qui ont été
accepté au titre du regroupement
familial Mo je veux bien qu'on me dise
que je parle pas assez fort mais j'ai
l'impression que beaucoup parlent à VO
basse par ailleurs qui facil mon
expression 14000 ressortissants de
nationalité étrangère sur 29000 demandes
14000 sur 29000 voilà exactement ce sur
quoi le Sénat attire notre attention le
Sénat propose plusieurs modifications du
droit existant il souhaite que la durée
de sé jour pour qu'un ressortissant
présent sur le territoire national
puisse demander le regroupement familial
pour sa femme son mari pour ses enfant
que cette durée de séjour soit portée de
18 mois à 24 mois propose ensuite que
l'âge des regoupants soit modifié
jusqu'à 21 ans je rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui c'est jusqu'à 18 ans pour
un mineur et c'est à partir de 18 ans
pour un conjoint là la limite serait
mise à 21 ans il propose ensuite
d'exclure les aides personnelles au
logement
de l'évaluation des ressources lorsque
le regroupant doit déposer évidemment
son dossier et le Sénat ajoute deux
éléments les ressources doivent être non
seulement stables et suffisantes mais
aussi régulières et ensuite la nécessité
pour le regroupant de prouver que son
assurance maladie permettra de de
couvrir les éventuelles difficultés des
futurs regroupés enfants ou conjoint
voilà exactement les C points sur
lequels le Sénat est intervenu sur ces
points je voudrais apporter un éclairage
durée de séjour d'abord aujourd'hui un
regroupant peut faire sa demande donc je
l'ai dit au bout de 18 mois l'autorité
administrative lui répond dans les 6
mois c'est-à-dire qu'au total la durée
réelle est de 24 mois et par conséquent
nous considérons qu'il est inutile de la
porter à 24 mois y compris parce que la
France a été condamnée par la Cour de
justice de l'Union européenne pour un
délai excessif supérieur à 24 mois et
que par conséquent si nous avions une
durée de séjour
madame jeunevar j'ai été clair
c'est-à-dire que la procédure fait que
la réponse intervient qu'à 24 mois et si
tout va bien s'il n'y a aucun retard et
d'ailleurs l'Allemagne elle-même a été
condamnée pour des durées excessives de
l'ordre de 30 à 36 mois nous irions
forcément dans cette direction je pense
que ça n'est pas souhaitable sur l'âge
des regroupements je je ne vois pas
l'intérêt de séparer plus longtemps
encore un enfant de ses parents le cas
échiant et donc nous vous proposons de
ne pas accepter l'âge porté à 20 un an
quant à l'exclusion des aides
personnelles au logement en réalité dès
à présent lorsque l'on doit évaluer la
condition de
ressources sont exclus les prestations
familiales sont exclus par exemple
minimum vieillesse toute une série de
dispositions qui sont déjà exclues moi
je souhaite que l'on conserve l'aide
personnelle au logement parce que c'est
lié aux conditions d'intégration
c'est-à-dire nous verrons tout à l'heure
dans un article à venir que la condition
de logement est très importante
c'est-à-dire la CAPAC capacité
d'intégration dans un logement qui soit
un logement capable d'accueillir une
famille et donc je crois qu'il serait
tout à fait inutile d'exclure les aides
personnelles au logement en revanche sur
la question de la régularité
stabilité ressources suffisantes et
régulière c'est cohérent doit pas
d'inconvénient majeur à ce que nous
puissions l'accepter d'illeurs cela et
je j'ai pu le vérifier ne remettraz pas
en cause par exemple un intermittent du
spectacle dont les ressources ne
seraient pas systématiques il faudrait
qu'elle soit à la fois stable suffisante
et régulière cette condition sera
toujours remplie et quant à la condition
d'assurance maladie je crois justifier
en effet qu'un regroupant dispose de la
capacité à faire en sorte que les futurs
regroupé soit couvert par son assurance
maladie là aussi pour des raisons qui
tiennent à leur capacité d'intégration
et de vie dans des conditions tout à
fait satisfaisantes sur notre territoire
national raison pour laquelle monsieur
le Président je donne avis défavorable à
l'ensemble des amendements de
suppression mais je propose moi-même un
amendement qui permettra de consolider
la condition de régularité ainsi que la
condition d'assurance maladie je vous
remercie al alors Monsieur le
Ministre merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président je reviens pas sur ce qu'a dit
monsieur le rapporteur général sauf
peut-être pour bien préciser
queeffectivement les conditions de
ressources que vérifient notamment les
maires et on aura l'occasion d'en
discuter puisque on sait tous que ce
sont les maires qui donnent un avis au
préfet et alors la question c'est est-ce
que tous les maires le font dans d'une
manière de
vérifier les propositions faites au
préfet est-ce que d'ailleurs ils le
savent pour une grande partie d'entre
eux qu'ils ont cette faculté de pas
laisser à leur service c'est un un
premier sujet mais les conditions de
ressources euh ne prévoi pas d'y mettre
les prestations social quel qu'elle soit
donc effectivement c'est c'est pas
fitatoire si les élus font leur travail
correctement comme ayant été maire j'ai
pu le faire mais on verra qu'il y a des
amendements de simplification ENF en
tout cas des propos de simplification
dans travail que font les maires j'ai
entendu cependant tout à l'heure sur ce
que disait monsieur Vallot sur et les
députésfi sur les conditions de langue
en disant que c'était contre la
Constitution et que ça n'a ce serait pas
constitutionnel et pas
conventionnel vous avez parlé par
ailleurs on imagine la réciprocité mais
je voudrais d'ailleurs dire que dans de
nombreux pays européens il y a ces
conditions de langue je pense par
exemple au gouvernement de Monsieur
Scholz qui a mis une condition de cours
de longue avec un test qui doit être
fait trois fois alors il est vrai qu'au
bout de trois fois s'il n'est pas réussi
on donne quand même le regroupement
familial mais il permet de mettre sa
disposition mais c'est aussi le cas du
gouvernement de Monsieur rut qui avait
mis cette disposition pour le
regroupement familial il s'agit pas de
faire un test de langue qui si n'est pas
réussi ne don pas droit regroupement
familial ça c'est ce que nous allons
prévoir pour le titre pluriannuel il
s'agit de obliger de prendre des cours
de français de prendre des cours de
français quand on est en perspective
d'un regoupement familial ça a déjà
existé d're pays notamment dans les
années 2007 2012 et continuer les deux
premières années du kakena de de
Monsieur Holland donc il s'agit pas d'un
d'un examen il s'agit de donner des
cours de français à ceux qui ont envie
de vivre familièrement dans notre pays
je considère d'ailleurs que c'est
d'autant plus important pour pour le
droit des femmes puisque l'essentiel de
cette de ce regoupement familial est un
un un regoupement féminin qui permet
ensuite de pouvoir vivre dans des
conditions qui ne sont pas des
conditions de de communautarisme ou de
d'enfermement dans une société qui ne
serait pas celle que nous souhaitons
pour pour la République je voudrais
terminer par par dire qu'en effet ça
touche entre 12000 et 14000 personnes
par an c'est juste de dire que le
groupement familial baisse et notamment
depuis 5 ans sur le territoire national
cependant il est tout à fait vrai aussi
de dire on aura d'autres questions sur
la réunification familiale qui concerne
les réfugiés et non pas les personnes
qui sont sur un titre de séjour
classique se territoire national que le
pourcentage de notre immigration même si
en volume chaque année l' immigration
familiale baisse reste majoritairement
familiale alors que nous cherchons avant
tout avoir une immigration de travail
donc même s'il s'agit de volumes qui
sont en effet pas très importants et
contrairement à ce qu'on peut ici ou là
lire qui ne qui ne remontte pas à à des
montants qui sont ceux de la demande
d'asile ou des visas étudiants il quand
même important de prévoir des conditions
d'intégration de ceux qui rejoignent le
territoire national c'est pour ça que
moi je je rejoins le proposition de
Monsieur rapporteur et invite à refuser
les amendements de suppression de cet
article alors j'ai d'inscrit monsieur
porte merci monsieur le Président ma
collègue fosson a brillamment défendu
l'amendement c'est une obsession une
obsession infondée une obsession raciste
le biais du regroupement familial est
utilisé pour cibler des personnes ça a
été rappelé ça ne représente un chiffre
qui est en baisse permanente moins de 10
% depuis 2005 contraire à l'article 8 de
la CEDH et on voit que ça répond aussi à
une question de de quand vous évoquez la
question des ressources c'est aussi une
immigration choisie c'est-à-dire celles
et ceux qui ont de l'argent pourront
faire venir leur famille et les autres
ne pourront pas la faire venir donc
c'est c'est absolument abject c'est dans
la droite ligne de ce qui est sorti
du Sénat mais monsieur le ministre vous
vous êtes dit favorable à ce que ce soit
limité le recours au regroupement
familial donc il y a quand même un
accord tacite une fois de plus entre la
macronie et la droite sur ce projet
migratoire qui on le voit ce soir dans
l'intégralité de nos débats qui est pas
à la hauteur des enjeux et qui un
concours Lespine de celui qui sera
quelque part le plus raciste et le plus
génophob pour avoir la la proposition la
plus horrible
mon simplement appeler à la cohérence
celles et ceux qui ont déposé des
amendements de supression et qui ont
lieu aussi bien que le rapporteur
général l'article introduit introduit au
Sénat m'interroger aussi sur le bien
fondé et même la faisabilité des
conditions de langue préalable
regroupement familial oui oui non mais
le ministre l'a évoqué donc je
m'autorise à à y répondre comment par
exemple par tout moyen une femme afghane
prendrait des cours de français avant de
venir en France dans le CAD r familial à
Kabou alors qu'elles nont même pasell
n'ont pas le droit d'être
scolarisé quel rapport bah le rapport
est que la condition de regroupement
familial préalablement enfin la maîtrise
du français préalementouement familiale
et et et pas
forcément pas forcément pas forcément ça
suppose que le mari é é est bénéficier
du statut de de de réfugié ce qui n'est
pas toujours le cas vous le savez voilà
moi j'en appelle la cohérence des
collègues qui ont appelé à fter la
suppression de pas se ranger aux
amendements du je peux je au
sousamendement du rapporteur après ou
maintenant monsieur
Lucas cet article illustration de la
droit de tartuf on proclame son amour de
la valeur travail on refuse des
régularisations par le travail et là on
proclame son amour de la famille allant
jusqu'à en défendre les conceptions les
plus archaïques mais on refuse que la
France permette à des familles d'être
réunies les valeurs familiales mes chers
collègues ne peuvent souffrir de la
moindre discrimination d'origine ou de
nationalité deux autres arguments quand
même chers collègues pour vous inciter à
à votter ses amendements de suppression
il y a pas d'inclusion possible dans la
société si on ne peut y vivre avec sa
famille voir ses enfants grandir dans le
pays où l'on vit c'est quand même une
évidence humaine qui devrait dépasser
les débat que nous avons par ailleurs le
droit au regroupement familial est déjà
largement restreint en France 18 mois
c'est bien au-delà du délai de nombre de
nos voisins on a déjà des conditions de
logement de ressources c'est quand même
une condition essentielle à l'inclusion
que de pouvoir construire ici avec les
siens son réseau affectif et
familial
monsieur
Dumont merci monsieur le Président sans
étonnement aucun les républicains
votreont contre ces amendements de
suppression parce que nous estimons en
effet qu'il y a quand même besoin de
réguler le regroupement familial en
effet c'est pas la principale source
d'entrée des motifs des visas pour motif
familial dans notre pays mais cela reste
un nombre important plusieurs milliers
par an et on l'a dit les stocks de
titres de séjour dans dé plais au
rapporteurs pour motif familial sont à
hauteur de plus de 1,3 million de titres
de séjour actuellement en vigueur dans
notre pays et représente plus d'un tiers
des titres de séjour qui sont en
circulation la question qui se pose ici
c'est pas la question d'accueillir tout
le monde sous n'importe quellees
condition la question est de savoir
quelles sont les conditions d'accueil
est-ce que vous trouvez qu'aujourd'hui
une personne un étranger en situation
régulière qui peut faire venir cinq
personnes de sa famille doit justifier
de 1500 € d'un appartement est-ce que ce
sont des conditions dignes d'accueil
est-ce que vous croyez vraiment qu'on
peut faire vivre 6 personnes avec 1500 €
par mois sans faire appel à la
solidarité nationale c'est évidemment
impossible et donc pour Monsieur
marangéi Merci monsieur le Président
euh le groupe horizon et apparenté
votera contre ces amendements de
suppression j'entends parler depuis tout
à l'heure
d'obsession les les termes sont
particulièrement excessifs de quoi
parlons-nous on parle de la capacité à
accueillir on parle de la capacité à
loger une famille d'avoir des ressources
régulières et stables permettre de
subvenir aux besoins d'une famille euh
je je ne vois pas d'excès aujourd'hui
à insérer ces dispositifs afin de
permettre tout simplement à ce que
l'accueil soit euh le mieux possible et
surtout ne repose pas sur la solidarité
nationale alors que celui ou celle qui
accueille n'est pas en capacité
d'accueillir sa famille donc le le
groupe horizon votera contre ces
amendements de suppression alors
monsieur le rapporteur général ensuite
on a Monsieur le Ministre et on votera
mais quel les éclairages notamment
monsieurpp j'ai oublié monsieur Gouffier
ah Monsieur
Gouffier non mais j'essai de faire vite
monsieur le Président le groupe
Renaissance sera opposé à ces
amendements de de suppression euh et
rejoindra le rapporteur général sur un
amendement que nous avons également
déposé juste après euh visant alors à
retirer un certain nombre de critères
qui ont été introduits par le Sénat
concernant les ressources financières
l'âge du conjoint concernant la durée de
séjour que nous écarterons par contre
nous estimons qu'il faut garder l'ajout
qui a été fait sur la couverture
médicale donc l'assurante maladie de
l'ensemble du du foyer travail qui
s'appuie sur la directive européenne du
22 septembre 2023 2003 et nous y
reviendrons dans dans quelques instants
monsieur le rapporteur non mais répondre
d'abord à Monsieur Valot que la femme
ressortissante de nationalité afghane
qui serait présente en
France ou qui viendrait al attendez si
elle est pas présente en France c'est
pas c'est pas le sujet je parle de la
personne qui serait mais dans ces
conditions elle viendra au titre de la
demande d'asile de son conjoint présent
s que et elle va donc bénéficier en
arrivant sur le territoire national mais
bien sûr que si et elle va elle va
arriver sur le territoire national en
bénéficiant à la fois de laada de la
Puma et donc de toutes les garanties de
protection qui sont nécessaires pourquoi
considérons-nous que la monsieur c'est à
moi qu'il faut répondre le caschant
parce que je
m'exprime pourquoi considérons-nous que
à la fois la régularité des ressources
et l'assurance maladie sont nécessaires
ce sont des mesures de protection ce
sont des mesures d'intégration ce sont
des mesures sur les de vigilance sur les
conditions d'accueil Monsieur Laurent
marcangelli le disait il y a quelques
instants la façon euh de dont les
enfants dont un conjoint une conjointe
venant sur le territoire national sera
euh couvert sur le plan de la maladie
vous trouvez que c'est une condition qui
est tout à fait superfitatoire et pour
le cas où vous naccepteriez pas c'est
une des conditions qui est déjà possible
au regard de la directive 2003 directive
européenne accueille ce n'est qu'un
alignement bien sûr que si ce n'est
qu'un alignement sur la directive
européenne donc ne faites pas comme si
cette condition était tout à fait
inacceptable je redis ma position celle
que je propose à travers l'amendement
que nous verrons dans quelques instants
nous ne sommes en désaccord avec
l'allongement de la durée de séjour
nécessaire avant de pouvoir faire la
demande de regroupement familial
considérons qu'elle est inutile et qu'en
plus elle nous mettrait sous le coup
possible de la jurisprudence européenne
nous sommes contre l'allogement de la
durée enfin de l'âge à 21 ans
considérons que ce serait une façon de
couper des familles et que ça n'est pas
acceptable ce n'est pas notre conception
de la même façon que nous considérons
que les APL n'ont pas à figurer doivent
figurer dans les conditions de
ressources parce que c'est lié à la
condition de logement que nous allons
examiner dans quelques instants et donc
c'est bien à la fois sur la régularité
et la seule assurance maladie que je
vous propose de conserver ces quelques
dispositions du
Sénat monsieur le ministre non mais
monsieur Vallot euh prenons l'exemple
que vous avez pris une femme afghane
donc j'imagine puisqu'elle n'est pas en
France elle est en Afghanistan bon elle
ne peut pas et là pour le coup monsieur
laall il faut qu'on soit sérieux elle ne
peut pas être en France au nom du
regoupement familial il n'y a plus de
consulat il n'y a plus d'ambassade il n
a plus de relation diplomatique avec les
talibans il n'y a plus de vol donc si
jamais elle devait avoir son familial
c'est qu'elle a quitté l'Afghanistan
elle est donc dans un pays où elle peut
faire un titre demande de titre de
séjour dans un pays où elle peut prendre
par ailleurs des cours de français sans
réussir cet examen bien sûr l'alliance
puis qu'il y a pas d'examen l'alliance
culturelle mais c'est quand même
incroyable que la gauche que vous
représentez ne veut pas qu'on puisse
donner des cours gratuits sans
obligation de les réussir de français à
des femmes pour venir sur notre sol
comment vous voulez lutter contre le
communautarisme monsieur vot en fait
mais non mais mais monsieur mais ne vous
énervez pas monsieur vot votre exemple
est nul et non avenu vous vous avez
raconté n'importe quoi mais vous avez
raconté n'importe quoi si la femme afgan
mais mais vous avez le droit d'être
contre vous avez le droit d'être contre
cette disposition mais pas en racontant
n'importe quoi la représentation
nationale qui nous regardent une femme à
c'est votre exemple monsieur Vallot
quelqu'un d'ussi intelligent que vous
mais ça m'étonne que vous priez cet
exemple là pour essayer de porter la
contradiction c'est très étonnant
qu'est-ce qui se passe si la femme
afghane est en Afghanistan et qu'elle
est effectivement pour chasser et en
imaginant en imaginant que son foyer
soit en dehors de de chez elle que son
mari ses enfants a déjà eu l'asile si
elle a eu l'asile si sa famille a eu
l'asile il y a la réunification
familiale il n'y a pas de condition si
elle n'a pas l'asile elle peut demander
asile visa pour revenir en France avec
cet asile 80 % c'est le tau de
protection des personnes afghanes qui en
plus pour les femmes montent à 90 % dans
certain nombre de cas et si jamais elle
n'est pas dans son pays qui est dans un
autre pays et bien elle va demander un
titre de séjour comme tout le monde on
du regroupement familial partant du
principe que son mari par exemple est en
France elle prendra des cours de
français il y aura pas d'obligation à ce
qu'elle réussisse un examen on ne
propose pas comme en Allemagne comme le
gouvernement monsur Scholz qui rappelle
je fais un un un une sorte de de
gouvernement avec les veres donc si le
gouvernement monsieur chos et
gouvernement avec les verres d'Allemagne
ont réussi à mettre un examen pour le
regroupement familial c'est qu'il est
quand même pas si inhumain que ça ça
permet de lutter mais c'est la vérité
première c'est les ver allemands qui
l'ont fait donc attendez quelques
instants ça permet simplement de donner
à des personnes quelques notions
quelques notions de la langue dans
lequelle ils vont venir on pas de
réussir un examen de prendre des cours
de langue je vois pas en quoi cette
possibilité d'émancipation et notamment
pour les femmes vous gêne tant sinon sin
vous allez accélérer un communautarisme
que vous refusez par ailleurs en tout
cas dans les propos votre exemple est
nul et non avenu il peut pas y avoir
familial venant
d'Afghanistan allez on vote ses
amendements de suppression qui vote pour
les amendements de
suppression
14 j'ai 14 + 4 ça fait 18 + 3 ça fait 21
qui vote
contre 17 + 8 ça fait déjà 25 ça passe
ils ne sont pas
adoptés monsieur le rapporteur j'ai déjà
présenté en réalité cet amendement en en
voulant resserrer le dispositif à la
conservation de la condition de
régularité des ressources et à celle de
l'Assurance
Maladie monsieur Lucas le
1994 le 994 pardon ce sera moi monsieur
le présid Président Madame Chatel oui
euh je vous remercie je voudrais quand
même revenir 2 minutes sur le débat que
nous avons eu puce qu'on a eu
l'impression que le débat était de
mettre des conditions à l'accueil par
une personne des membres de sa famille
comme s'il n'en existait pas je vais
vous lire aujourd'hui ce qui est inscrit
dans la loi c'estàd que au titre du
regroupement familial pour faire venir
sa famille il faut justifier de
ressources stables et suffisantes pour
subvenir au besoins de sa famille donc
tous les arguments que nous avons
entendu préalablement sont nuls et non
avenus il faut disposer ou disposera la
date d'arrivée de sa famille en France
d'un logement considéré comme normal
pour une famille comparable vivant dans
la même région géographique dire que
toutes les les l'argumentaire du Ren et
l'une et nonavenu il faut se conformer
au principes essentiel qui conformément
au loi de la République régisse la vie
familiale en France pays d'accueil donc
voilà on voit bien que là on n'est pas
dans un risque de communautarisme donc
est-ce qu'on pourrait arrêter de faire
croire qu'on est en train d'écrire pour
la première fois le droit du cuœil de la
code et l'entrée on aurait dû supprimer
cet article nous aurions dû le supprimer
nous nous prons à minima d'enlever euh
des dispositions qui vivent encore plus
à restreintre ce droit de vivre en
famille par toutes et tous monsieur
Gouffier le 15 le 1543 oui merci
monsieur le Président amendement que
j'ai également présenté il y a quelques
instants tout comme le rapporteur
général et qui vient resserrer le
dispositif en ne conservant que l'ajou
relatif à l'assurance maladie
c'est-à-dire que nous demanderions au
regroupant de fournir la preuve qu'il
dispose bien d'une assurance maladie
couvrant l'ensemble des risques que
normalement couvert pour ses propres
ressentissants dans l'État membre
concerné pour lui-même et les membres de
sa famille je vous
remercie défavorable à l'amendement de
pardon merci euh monsieur le Président
j'ai souvenir il y a euh 1 an et demi de
députés enfin de de de macronist nous
disant qu'il fallait voter pour eux pour
faire barrage au rassemblement national
et là on a un article rajouté par les
républicains pour en attenter au
regroupement familial c'est-à-dire pour
en attenter au fait que les gens
puissent s'aimer et se rassembler quand
ils s'aiment amendement qui voulait être
supprimé par le président de notre
commission macroniste par des membres du
MoDem macroniste par un certain nombre
de nos collègues macronistes qui sont
fidèles à cette idée qu'il faut faire
barrage aux idées du rassemblement
national et puis de l'autre côté et bien
on a eu un vote de certains macronistes
du rapporteur de Monsieur Darmanin même
s'il peut pas voter mais il était
d'accord avec le rassemblement national
et les républicains mettez-vous d'accord
mettez-vous d'accord qu'est-ce que vous
essayez de faire avec ce texte vous
essayez de faire des choses utiles pour
notre patrie ou vous essayez de prendre
les arguments et les objectifs du
rassemblement national et de les faire
progresser monsieur par Madame Chatelin
oui merci euh monsieur le le Président
je je voulais je voulais finir mon
argumentaire comme je v l'ai démontrer
la question le regroupement familial a
déjà fait l'objet de plusieurs
modifications visant toujours à
restreindre les conditions du
regroupement familial nous nous opposons
à cette logique qui vise toujours plus à
restreindre et à un moment quand
j'écoute les argumentaires que ça soit
du rassemblement national des
républicains ou même aujourd'hui de
renaissance euh je me demande mais en
fait finalement qui pourra faire venir
sa famille est-ce que ce droit est
réservé uniquement au plus riches je ne
le crois pas surtout dans une société où
on a des personnes de plus en plus
précaires des personnes de plus en plus
pauvres où ce loger devient de plus en
plus difficile pour de nombreuses
personnes continuer à restreindre le
droit au regroupement familial revient à
dire pour vivre en famille soyez riches
et pour ça pour moi c'est inacceptable
c'est un droit qui
qui doit être libre pour l'ensemble des
personnes quel que soit leur revenu
monsieur de la portec même je
monsieur le rapporteur pourtant vous qui
venez d'une région vidicole vous devriez
le savoir vous êtes en train de boire le
calice jusqu'à la lie parce que on a
commencé par mettre en place les quotas
alors dans votre glose j'ose le dire
jésuistique vous osez dire tout
simplement que ce n'est plus des quotas
mais des objectifs et derrière une fois
que vous avez mis les objectifs B vous
regardez comment faire pour les faire
appliquer qu'est-ce que vous faites vous
Durc c'est le regroupement familial vous
allez demandé du coup de faire la preuve
d'une assurance maladie parce que oui
derrière vous allez durcir l'aide
médicale d'État même si aujourd'hui vous
dites on y touchera pas mais j'attends
de voir la suite parce que on a un
système et donc je vous demanderai
monsieur le rapporteur peut-être de nous
expliquer ce que vous attendez par
assurance maladie est-ce que par exemple
je prends l'exemple d'une médecin qui
est Pasu chez moi qui demande
aujourd'hui un regroupement familial
est-ce qu'elle doit demander aux
personnes dans le pays d'où ils viennent
d'avoir eu par exemple au Maroc une
assurance Madie où est-ce qu'il faut
qu'elle est déjà en France pour sa
famille merci monsieur le Président nous
nous considérons au républicains que ce
droit au regroupement familial n'est pas
inconditionnel c'est la raison pour
laquelle le Sénat avait émis un certain
nombre de conditions vous en retenez
fort peu monsieur le rapporteur général
vous ne retenez que l'obligation de
souscrire à une Assur maladie pour
l'ensemble de la famille
et des ressources suffisantes stables et
régulières le compte n'y est pas pour
nous le compte n'y est pas et notamment
de ne pas prendre en compte les APL qui
sont des prestations non des ressources
non contributives c'est la raison pour
laquelle le Sénat les a exclus et les
mesures d'âge non plus ne sont pas
retenu c'est pourquoi nous sommes pas du
tout satisfaits de la proposition que
vous faites monsieur Gouffier
non c'est Monsieur monsieur Gouffier
monsieur
mendz non alors Monsieur mendz pardon je
moi monsieur Gouffier Ava une demande de
retrait donc nous on retirera
l'amendement du groupe Renaissance au
profit du de l'amendement proposé par le
rapporteur général OK et donc enfin
Monsieur nagelen Merci monsieur le
Président c'est à un mon donné il faut
arrêter d'être dans les excès qu'est-ce
qu'on apporte aujourd'hui et qu'est-ce
qui est qu'est-ce qui va être voté c'est
simplement le fait d'ajouter régulier
pour les ressources et d'y ajouter une
assurance maladie pour soi-même et pour
les membres de sa famille je dire à un
moment donné ça reste quelque chose de
relativement légitime dès lors qu'on
accueille quelqu'un dans notre dans
notre pays donc je pense qu'à un moment
donné depuis tout à l'heure on a le
droit à à un certain nombre un certain
nombre d'excès voire même à être traité
de de raciste ou de xénophobe dès lors
qu'on n pas qu'on n pas en en d'accord
avec ce qui est dit par une certaine
partie de cette de cette commission en
réalité voilà c'est c'est c'est pas et
d'ailleurs le Canada le Canada je pense
pas que ce soit une une dictature c'est
pas non plus un pays raciste et au
Canada aussi on demande à ce qu'il y a
une assurance maladie pour soi-même et
pour la famille bon alors l'amendement
du rapporteur qui vote
pour qui vote
contre il est adopté
alors il fait tomber le
994 le 550 le 1542 le 459 le 466 le 1132
le 1225 et le 1133 et donc on peut le
225 oui c'est ça donc le 255 monsieur
gilet 250
ou monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues en 74 le
gouvernement a mis fin à l'immigration
pour motif économique en raison de
l'augmentation du chômage et 2 ans plus
tard en 76 il prend un décret autorisant
le regroupement familial depuis cette
date l'immigration a échappé à toute
régulation les Français ont subi faute
de volonté politique pour la maîtriser
une immigration hors de contrôle et
empêche chaque jour le prix toujours
plus fort après la loi de 2018 pour une
immigration maîtrisée un droit asile
effectif et une intégration réussie qui
porte très mal son nom le cadre
juridique permettant une immigration
légale n' cessé d'être de plus en plus
favorable à une immigration incontrôlée
devenu un véritable outil pour
l'immigration de peuplement le
regroupement familial doit être repris
en main et mieux encadré en 2021 l'INC
estimé à 5,1 million le nombre
d'étrangers résidants en France soit 7,6
% de la population à un tel rythme en
2025 ils représenteront plus d'un/art de
la population
totale ainsi cet amendement
vise
défavorable madame Chatelin oui merci
Monsieur le le président n là une un
argumentaire avec typique du
rassemblement national et de leur
obsession avec deux choses il y aurait
une immigration incontrôlée ce n'est pas
le cas c'est été dit à plusieurs
reprises aujourd'hui nous sommes très
loin d'une immigration contrôlée la
deuxième chose c'est cette idée
d'immigration du peuplement derrière
laquelle se cache tout le fantasme du
Grand remplacement je le dis aujourd'hui
ce soir dans les rues de Lyon on avait
100 à 150 militants d'extrême droite qui
étaient en train de crier Islam hors
d'Europe l'immigration tue qui était
habillé tout de noir ce sont les mêmes
qui il y a quelques semaines étaient en
train d'attaquer la maison du passage à
Lyon la première chose c'est Monsieur le
Ministre déjà quand est-ce qu'alz-vous
dissoudre ces regroupements être
extrêmement ferme contre l'extrême
droite allez-vous attendre que comme en
Norvège nous ayons des attentats parce
qu' Anders Brevic le 22 juin 2011 tue 77
personnes fait 150 blessés sur des
textes fondés sur l'idéologie
complletiste de Rabia qu'on retrouve
dans cette logique du remplacement et
même Brenton voudra làdessus a tué 50
personnes
etexex
non je veux pas vous couper je je je non
non non plus la parole c'est une minute
pour tout le
mondeoc non Monsieur B on essaie de
terminer ce soir l'article 1ier B je
donc s vous pe rester je suis assez
choqué mais c'est pas la première fois
depuis le début de la matin enfin la
journée par les propos du du du non pas
du rassemblement national on peut dire
du Front national parce que là ce sont
concrètement les mêmes arguis qu'on
entendait dans les années 80 de la part
de Monsieur Le Pen pè et ce qui est
assez choquant c'est que dans c'est dans
le les termes que vous avez employé vous
avez parlé de d'immigration de
peuplement entre dans cette idée de du
du Grand remplacement en réalité donc
franchement c'est c'est un une confusion
de genre terrible le le rassemblement
familial le regroupement familial c'est
quoi c'est tout
simplement quelque chose d'humain c'est
de dire que des gens qui sont venus
travailler dans notre pays et on on
était heureux de les avoir dans les
années 70 justement les usines
citroënes
tous ces endroits où les gens ont été
travaillés on produit pour la France à
un moment donné leur famille a voulu
revenir et on les a autorisé à revenir
av je mets donc au voix l'amendement 255
qui vote pour contre rejeté le 601
monsieur nagelen
oui cet amendement est est très simple
et il vient compléter l'article
434-6 cza en y rajoutant un 4e alinéa
qui est qu'un membre de la famille dont
le comportement serait contraire au
principe de la République qui régisse la
vie familiale en France c'est-à-dire de
manière très simple dans les critères
d'exclusion on a aujourd'hui euh la la
menace à l'ordre public mais il y a
certaines choses qui sont différences
entre la menace à l'ordre public et les
principes républicains je prends par
exemple un un thème très simple
l'égalité homme-femme l'égalité
hommes-femme est un principe qui est
c'est un principe de la République et
donc il faut que quelqu'un qui vienne en
France dans le cadre du regroupement
familial soit favorable à cette égalité
hommesfemm qui est un principe
républicain simple et il y a un certain
nombre d'autres exemples qui vont dans
dans ce
sensl monsieur le rapporteur oui je
voudrais simplement répondre à la
présidente châelin tout à l'heure vous
avez dit et je répondrai bien sûr à
Christophe vous avez dit on crée le
regroupement familial pour les riches
mais pas du tout la condition de
ressources elle n'est pas modifiée ce
sera toujours 1300 € pour deux à tr
personnes000 400 € pour 3 4 5 personnes
il n'y a aucune modification du niveau
de ressource qui est exigé par voie de
décret en rien non mais al dans ces
conditions ne dites pas des choses
pardon madame la Présidente mais que
vous ne savez pas non mais vous avez dit
vous changez les modifications les les
conditions vous modifiez vous avez
expliqué que nous modifions le niveau de
ressources c'est faux vous avez dit que
nous modifions le niveau de ressources
et que donc nous réservions leoup
familial au riches c'est faux le niveau
de ressources ne sera pas du tout
modifié vous avez dit quelque chose qui
est tout à fait inexacte et ensuite
monsieur nagelen pour répondre à à votre
à votre amendement j'aurais j'aurais
voulu l'adopter parce que je suis
conforme au droits existant mais c'est
déjà prévu dans le czda et il n'y a pas
d'utilité de le rajouter à l'article 434
je vais y arriver 6 du czda alors qu'il
est déjà présent à l'article
434-7 où il faut que le regroupant et
les regroupés se conformment je je cite
auprès principes essentiels qui
conformément au loi de la République
résiste la vie familiale en France pays
d'accueil c'est le 3ème bulle du
l434-7 et pour cette raison il n'est pas
utile de l'ajouter à l'amendement
précédent l'article pardon précédent
donc défavorable ou retrait pour cette
raison monsieur nagelen monsieur
monsieur nagelen non le l'article 434-7
dit l'étranger qui en fait la demande
est autorisé à être rejoint c'est-à-dire
que il est tandis que dans le 430 4- 6
c'est l'étranger qui veut rejoindre donc
on n'est pas on n'est pas tout à fait
sur la même sur la même chose un complé
alors allez-y monsieur le rapporteur
alors vous avez raison j'ai été un peu
trop vite dans mon raisonnement toutes
mes excuses mais il n'empêche que au
regarde l'article 13 don nous débattrons
dans plusieurs jours et regarde les
conditions qui sont posées par l'article
13 vous serez totalement satisfait par
l'article 13 il sera inutile de
l'ajouter dans le césda mais l'article
13 sera en conformité avec avec vos
souit vos objectifs madame
Martin merci
euh une vision de l'étranger xénophobe
est une vision qui superpose à cette
vision de l'étranger les notions de de
délinquence voire pourquoi pas au gré au
gré des faits divers ou des événements
de de terroristes voilà ce qu'il en est
voilà la raison pour laquelle nous
parlons de cette façon-là d'ailleurs
c'est tout à fait formidable ce à quoi
nous assistons tout au moins remarquable
puisquen 6h30 vous avez réussi à
introduire la notion de quota même si on
l'a appelé différemment et là maintenant
à réduire le regroupement familial sous
diverses diverses aspects donc là
maintenant on nous parle de respect des
principes
républicains bon le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est que cela paraî très vague
donc non seulement votre loi n'est que
régression du point de vue des droits y
compris fondamentaux des des exilés
d'une manière générale mais vous
introduisez aussi des choses qui
permettront je mets au voix l'amendement
601 qui vote pour qui vote contre il est
rejeté et comme manifestement vous
n'avez pas envie d'en terminer ce soir
et bien je lève la commission bonne
nuit